and there'll be some times where the
presenters are going faster than my head
is spinning so uh I may need to go back
and look at some here okay thank
you does it look like our guests are are
um in the waiting room or wherever they
go it does should I bring them in please
morning
everyone good morning
[Music]
um representative wer sir are you ready
I'm
ready so being
930 uh I'll read the checklist for the
uh right to no meeting
requirements as chair of division three
of the house finance committee I find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor Governor as a
result of covid-19 pandemic in
accordance with the governor's emergency
order number 12 which was pursuant to
executive order
2020-4 as
extended this public body is authorized
to meet electronically please note there
is no physical location to observe uh
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting which was authorized pursuant to
the
governor's however in accordance with
the emergency order I am confirming
several things we are a providing public
access to the meeting by telephone with
additional access possibilities by video
or other electronic means we are us
utilizing the zoom video webinar for
this remote meeting all members of the
committee and the staff of state
agencies with agenda items have the
ability to communicate
contemporaneously somebody's not on mute
just thought I'd give you a heads up um
during this meeting through this
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously watch and or listen to
the meeting on Zoom or phone directions
and links provided in the house calendar
and there's a uh link there to uh House
calendar number eight it's on the Gen
Court page B providing public notice of
the necessary information for accessing
this meeting meting we previously gave
notice of to the public of the necessary
information for accessing the meeting
telephonically instructions have been
provided in the house calendar
calar is eight he hey representative be
if if you put us on yourself on mute
until you're ready to speak
please um thank you C providing a
mechanism for the public to alert the
public body during the meeting if there
are problems with access if anybody has
a problem please email uh
lore fiscal f i s c at leg. state. n.
us D adjourning the meeting of the
public is unable to access the meeting
in the event The public's unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled um please note
that if we take a vote all those votes
uh will be done by a roll call so uh
with that uh Mr clerk let's start the
meeting by taking a roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
uh it would be great if each would also
State whether there is anyone in the
room with you during this meeting and
that's required under our right to know
law thank you Mr chairman representative
Earth presid alone in my home
office president wer I'm alone in this
room there are others in the house in
Kingston New Hamp with
me representative
Bean I'm president I'm at my home my
wife is in and
out representative
walner president and I am in my home in
conquered and um I'm alone
representative
nordr represent nordr here I'm in my
dining room in Hanover all by
myself representative Rogers I am in um
conquer in my apartment and alone except
for my dog Romeo who will be popping up
now and then representative
th representative
Edwards uh I'm present in my office in
Auburn I have family in the house but
they're not likely to come into my
office uh Mr chairman all committee
members of division three of pres thank
you thank you so much I'm going to try
to share
something uh that's not what I intended
to
share so I was trying to what I'm trying
share how do I unshare stop share okay
what I was attempting to share was the
um the the the people that were
expecting to hear briefings from today
um Mr Ripple you sent me an email that I
just attempted to to share and I didn't
do it very well so uh oh wait a second
here we go I bet you this is
it uh can you see the email that says
we're gonna start at 9:30 okay all right
so this is the game plan for today I
want to verify with you Mr Ripple that
this is everyone that you think we're
going to talk to today from the overview
of DHHS all the way to the information
systems uh uh department down at the
bottom that is correct that's all I
expect today um as mentioned there may
be other people in addition to the names
mentioned here who are able to
answer questions posed by the committee
okay topics are defined here
yes so um with that I think we're
getting ready to
introduce um commissioner
Chev and it's a yes ma'am uh
representative nordgren do you have
something uh yeah
[Music]
I'm um the the email sold up there so I
couldn't see sorry um so I'm just
wanting to know if you could explain uh
what the plan is for today um we got
this sheet of paper um that lists where
all the pages are in our huge book um
and so I'm wondering if we're supposed
to be looking at the budget book while
be we're hearing these pres
presentations now and for the next few
days or are we going to have
presentations and then start the work of
going through the budget Page by
page at a later
date clarification that that that's a
that's a very fine question uh here here
was my concept I wanted to start out by
making sure that we understood who the
speakers and departments were for the
day that's why I shared that email um
and with that confirmed prior to each
individual starting their Department my
intent is to take a few moments
administratively to make sure that we
all have the the right part of the
spreadsheet up and the right part of the
PowerPoint ready to share and and we'll
go through uh as the Departments of um
uh prepared for us today uh at which
point when they conclude we'll ask
questions at the end and if you have a
question in the middle just raise your
hand and and we'll interrupt and you you
have a followup go ahead thank you
followup so so we're supposed to have
our big budget book beside us also so we
can go back and forth during the
presentation is that what you're saying
I'm confused I'm sorry we we no that's
fine I'm I'm probably is speaking so um
the budget book is not yet available I
think that got clarified by Mr Ripple in
the email last night that uh the our
budget book has not been printed it's
not been mailed out what we have
received are emails with the spreadsheet
emails with the draft uh house bill
to is you that doesn't look like go
ahead Mr Ripple sure I was just going to
comment that I think everyone was mailed
a hard copy of the governor's recommend
budget is that right so you should have
what you don't have is the briefing book
to be provided by HHS and I think you'll
get that by early next week latest so my
expectation and the committee may have a
different idea was that following each
presentation for each division uh the
department would then walk you through
the budget Pages for that division so my
thought was that you would actually be
looking at the budget Pages starting
today
does that answer your question
representative norg yes that's not the
way we've done it before so thank you
for the
clarification okay and um I knew that we
got the big binder I I thought we were
referring to the budget book which is
something
different um all right um so
commissioner chabanet I I uh and then uh
represent not representative but um Miss
rounds is is uh Co co-starring with you
today yes yes I will um if you're ready
I'll go ahead and kick us off and share
my screen okay uh before we do that I
just want to uh make sure that you're
welcomed to the committee um this is
going to be a little bit different than
the way you've done it in the past I'm
sure uh I I I I I wanted to introduce
myself uh to you to say that I have a a
long career in in the Army and working
with budgets and and when I take a look
at budgets I have very specific
questions uh my goal is to understand
the underlying operations in the
military we used to say no money no
Mission and the opposite is also true if
you have a mission we need to finance it
appropriately in order to get it done so
what my goal is in these meetings is to
really get to understand more about your
operations I took a look at your present
presentation that you put together M RS
and it looks like you took the template
that got sent to you by Mr Ripple and
that you attempted to incorporate U
parts of it into your presentation is
that right correct yes I believe that
will answer virtually all your questions
okay I really do appreciate that that's
going to help me a great deal and so
with that um if uh if you need some help
sharing your your your uh presentation
you you may start great thank you um so
first I just introduce myself I'm Karen
rounds I'm the Chief Financial Officer
for the Department I've been with the
Department three years um the first
presentation we're going to do today is
an overview of DHHS and our overall
budget and then we're going to start
going through the oom uh Office of the
commissioner budgets uh Lori Weaver will
kick us off there and then I will um use
my accounting unit uh for finance and
contracts as our guinea pig if you will
to sort of walk through how we how we
might go through this process and
hopefully that will answer a lot of the
questions um that you have on on how we
typically go through it um so with that
I'm going to go ahead and
[Music]
share my screen and the
presentation okay and I'm going to go
ahead and turn it over to commissioner
shanet
good morning everyone and thank you for
the opportunity to uh sit and talk a
little bit about the department and what
we
do I think most of you know that uh
we've spent the last year largely
focused on covid uh DHHS it's uh been a
trying year for sure but we are looking
forward to being more future oriented
and forward-looking um some of that is
with the hope that we're about to see
some relief from covid so that we can go
back to focusing on some of the things
that we were doing prior to covid and
and really start looking at the impact
on covid and trying to pull some of our
vulnerable back into um society and
their communities um in the in a way in
which they were prior to covid and
probably in a better position
postco
so what what you're going to see
throughout the budget uh is is really
focused on transformational change of
our systems um what we've discovered
during covid is definitely some gaps in
our system but a lot of the things that
that we're focusing on in the next
biennium are things that uh that we've
been working on more on a micro level
and you know part of the mission is to
zoom back and say what do we really need
to do with this system or this this
operation to to make it to be
transformative and transformation
doesn't just involve transforming the
systems of
care um through operations and
infrastructure but it also involves
transforming
perspective and sometimes that means
redefining how we think of things on how
care should be provided who should be
providing care so I think what you're
going to see interweaved into this
budget and into what our mission is for
the next couple of years is really
looking at our systems and how uh we
Define them how we should be redefining
them and really about um building on
strategy and transformation of our
systems so if we want to go to the next
slide I'm just going to give you a
general overview of our mission and you
will see that our mission is to join
families and communities providing
opportunities for citizens to achieve
Health meeting the the the basic human
needs and the health need and providing
treatment and support for our most
vulnerable residents and to protect and
care for New Hampshire so although this
is our
mission the one thing that I do want to
point out hello are are you are you
willing to take questions or do you want
to go all the way through to the end
before you take any questions like like
on this page I want to ask if this is a
statutory Mission or if this is a
mission that's been developed um through
years of
experience so that is definitely
something that I'm I'm gonna have to go
back and look at how the mission of the
department was developed our mission and
our mission statement is much longer
than this this is a just a a brief
snippet of what's in our mission but I
can find out its development I know that
it's been around for a long time um so I
can we can do some digging and find out
how this Mission came to be okay I'm
sorry to interrupt you but it's just
that this is going to be a consistent
point that M rounds May pick up on is
that I I I think it's important for us
to be able to distinguish between the
missions that you have statutorily
versus the missions that have been
adopted or taken on because they're just
good for the general public so I I'd
like to know where those boundaries are
uh as as I learn your department more
deeply
okay great we can do that so one of the
things that I want to point out in in
our mission is that although this is the
mission of the department it is not only
our
responsibility um a lot of times what
you'll hear either through media or
through legislative hearings is that
this is the state's responsibility to
take care of the vulnerable residents
and although it is part of our mission
and our
responsibility many of our initiatives
in in the coming two years will involve
working with our partners in the
community to enhance care in the
community because it is also the
community's uh responsibility to take
care of of our vulnerable residents
whether that be other Health Care
Systems our hospitals our community
health providers um in communities in
general we all have a collective
responsibility to take care of our most
vulnerable
citizens next slide Karen
so some of the key roles for DHHS you
will see um number one is to educate the
public and we do this in a variety of of
ways through both Direct Care uh direct
client facing services and also through
you know our Public Health Department
who does a who does a ton of public
education around all things uh Public
Health uh deliver services to clients
you will see that we have many client
facing services that we uh that we are
responsible for both our district
offices around the state that does
eligibility um we have a call center and
then we have all you know some of our
our uh Direct Care Providers which you
which you probably know very well New
Hampshire hospital Glen Cliff home um we
have a drf uh in Laconia and the sununu
center all uh state run direct service
providers uh to our
clients and then protect the health and
safety of our citizens we protect the
most vulnerable ensure prevention work
is done to prevent becoming vulnerable
um and much of that is done in public
health and through some of our you know
DCF and Adult Protective Services
programs we provide regulatory oversight
to all of these entities Health
Facilities Child Care Facilities food
service and public health disease
prevention and surveillance we do this
through licensing and certification in
most areas but we do have a very
prominent role in regulatory oversight
and then ensure program in operational
integrity and I I think what you will
see this bium as we look at
transformation partnership with our our
community providers it's more of a focus
on this to ensure that when we fund or
we provide grants to Our Community
Partners that the programs that being
delivered have the outcomes that we
anticipated and I think you know
historically I think that we work very
hard to um to fund and provide
programming to different areas of our
state and once it's going we're we're
we're happy and we're thrilled and it's
not often that we take a step back and
say now are the outcomes of that program
what we expected to be 3 years ago or
four years ago when we first started the
program how are they measuring up and
and I think what you will see in the
next two years is more of a focus on
that that we start to evaluate you know
um how are our doorway programs doing
how are Community Mental Health Services
being provided um how how are all of our
contracts being provided and are we
expecting the outcomes how are how is
Medicaid doing one of the B you know the
biggest contracts in state government
are Medicaid managed care you know how
is that model for de Hampshire are we
are we seeing the outcomes that we
anticip ipated and and the program and
operational Integrity part of the
department is going to be really
important in those
evaluations next slide Karen thank you
this is the overview of how the
department is structured um you will see
that we're broken up into four or five
different areas uh and then some sub
areas under that this is uh this has
been the organizational structure uh for
the last couple years in the department
it works well in the in our current
structure as we start looking at
transformational change in the
department in both our systems and our
definitions I think that you will see
some change in the organizational
structure of the
department next
slide this is the general Staffing of
the department and you will see that we
have a grand total of
3,226 positions in the department of
notes
that since the beginning of covid and
hence the hiring freeze and just the
general um the the climate in the
environment of working with covid we
have 760 positions open which is about
20% of our our total positions um with
the lifting of the hiring frees uh we do
expect to be agressively recruiting for
those 760 positions but it certainly has
impacted our ability um at the
department over the last uh six months
or so to really uh get out and be
proactive in a lot of the things we've
done like I've said a lot of the work
that we've done for the past year has
been on covid and that's although covid
sits in public health it really has been
a full Department effort we have um
staff from every area of the department
helping out in covid operations so this
is going to be a significant effort on
our part for the next two years is to
take that V can see right down and to
fill those position that we can be
transformative next slide
Karen so I just want to touch a little
bit of the impact
on um there there's the impact has been
widespread but I'm going to highlight a
couple the public health response
obviously they are at the Forefront of
everything we're doing on covid um you
see Dr Chan and Dr Daly um speaking at
our press conferences each week they are
really leading the these efforts in in
the public health Forum um some of the
things that we do the case
investigations and the contact tracing
being um probably one of the uh most
significant parts of our covid response
but then education uh around schools in
nursing homes University Systems in the
general public we do a ton of Education
we have partner calls probably every day
of the week with different entities from
school nurses School administrators
colleges
universities uh long-term care
facilities home care providers uh
regularly meeting with them the hospital
Association to provide education around
that and then testing which was a sign
Madam commissioner um sorry to interrupt
you again but uh represent walner has a
a break at 10 o'clock she needs and
she's got a question so I I thought I'd
give her chance to ask her question
sure thank you commissioner and I'm
sorry to to um interrupt your your
presentation like that I'm sorry I
actually had a question back on the
Staffing
page yeah I had my I didn't get my hand
up in time I guess while you were on the
page I'm sorry
um so when I look at this it says these
are the permanent positions through the
governor's phase so are these the
proposed positions for the next budget
the budget we're working on now or are
these the uh positions that you have now
that are
authorized Kin I'm gonna let you answer
that sure so it's actually both um but
they so it's all of our currently
authorized positions and it also is um
some additional positions none of which
are really new the only new positions we
had this year were conversions where we
converted temporary positions into
permanent positions those were the only
new positions we submitted um and those
were all approved uh there
was I don't remember the exact number
throughout the department but there was
a large number of those at New Hampshire
hospital which were the positions that
will um
will work on the unit that was converted
from a children's unit to an adult unit
so those are the majority of the new and
I put new in quotation marks but new
positions um that were all conversions
from temporary positions to permanent
positions
thank do do you have a followup
representative walner yes could I just
have a a quick followup yes ma'am so um
how many
new positions are you requesting
in the budget we're looking at now the
the next budget we actually did not
request any new positions we only
requested converting temporary
positions okay and could I have one more
question all of those go
ahead so there are no new positions um
are there any positions that you had in
the previous budget that are not
included in the next budget so there is
one position that you will see in hb1
that shows as being abolished um and uh
that position is being replaced by a new
permanent position uh we needed to
retire the position
number okay so for positions you would
say this is a a budget that is sort of
flat as far as positions go it's not up
or down for the most part we still have
uh about 70ish unfunded positions um
throughout the department but um other
than that yes the positions still exist
they're just not
funded thank you and thank you chairman
for letting me ask those questions and
I'm sorry we had to go back you're very
welcome there good questions I I had a a
similar one on this particular slide
could we we could we see what the
numbers were um in the prior two budget
Cycles so that it sounds like there's uh
not a growth Trend but it'd be nice to
see the numbers from the from the prior
to
[Music]
banians I can do that what I would warn
you of um and anyone that was on the
committee last year will remember this
is last banum we did a lot of cleanup
work with putting positions in the right
place um so much so that it was very
frustrating for all of us because it was
hard to follow where all the positions
went so I would say that the grand total
over the vums is probably going to be a
more helpful number than by division
because the division numbers would have
shifted a lot but I will still provide
it that way just be warned that it's
probably not going to make a lot of
sense thank you for that representative
Earth already warned me that they was
going to make explode and representative
Earth will be happy to hear that there
were very few I movements this year I I
would say less than 40 which is very low
for us so so if there are no further
questions uh commissioner would you like
to go back to where you were
sure um so we were on the impact of
covid and we had talked about the public
health response um everything from um
doing education case investigation
contact facing testing nursing home
investigations
um but really a full Department response
Public Health taking the lead on that
the Medicaid case loads largely um going
up um and Karen will explain this
further down when Karen and Henry when
you get to the Medicaid budget that uh
the federal government increased our
fmap which is our federal uh alloc our
federal share of Medicaid but the
requirement in that increase was that we
not take anybody off Medicaid during the
covid emergency so you will see
increasing Medicaid case loads um every
population that dhh serves was affected
um every from you're hearing right now
about um children's Behavioral Health in
ER boarding you definitely have heard
about our seniors the nursing home and
the homebound that have been
disproportionately affected by covid
having uh some of the worst outcomes uh
for from covid across the country and
really across the globe that's not that
is not New Hampshire issue that is uh
really we're seeing that Trend across
the across the entire country and
overall you know the impact on isolation
is probably the most significant thing
that we've seen um when it comes to DHHS
and that that really crosses all all
populations from people with mental
illness people with
disabilities um you know kids not being
in school the impact on that lack of
social support the lack of peer support
support and the the general isolation
that covid has caused our communities is
being felt in every area of the
department and then finally the budget
impact on Alvarez and Marcel um so back
almost a year ago we were facing an
uncertain deficit in our budget
and we agreed that we should bring on a
a consulting firm to look at our our
department both operationally and
budget-wise to see if we can find
efficiencies um efficiencies and how we
run operations efficiencies in our
budget and we did do that and uh Alvarez
and Marcel or A&M as we've called it was
embedded in the department for several
months and uh really have been very
helpful so some of the things that uh
came out of that that review and what
you will see coming through into the the
budget that you have before you
um a recommendation to do an IMD waiver
which is a waiver that allows us to bill
for Medicaid for inpatient adults at New
Hampshire hospital this is uh very
beneficial for us right now uh adults
that are in an impatient stay at an IMD
that's an in Institution for mental
disease uh are not eligible for Medicaid
reimbursement which has a 50% uh Federal
share so we will be filing that waiver
hopefully to be done by the end of the
year the other the other indirect uh
effect of having an IMD waiver is that
it allows us to attract and to to
partner with other um inpatient Partners
so right now we have New Hampshire
hospital and some drfs scattered
throughout the state many states have
inpatient providers that are outside of
the state system that run you know pool
psychiatric hospitals no one um no
company is going to be willing willing
to come to New Hampshire without this
IMD waiver so this this hopefully is
going to be the start of finding a new
partner representative Edwards thank you
I'm trying to find the most graceful way
to interrupt you uh we got a question
from a representative
Earth commissioner are we gonna get a
copy of that
review yes yes um I do believe it is
going to be released publicly if not the
end of this than early next week thank
you
y um so that's IMD waiver uh critical
time intervention also called CTI is
something that uh that came out of this
review and what CTI is it's a
evidence-based PR uh program for people
that have mental illness that is that is
done to reduce readmission rates to
hospital this is something that uh I'm
actually very excited about most most of
you know I'm a big proponent of our
mental health system after spending a
couple of years at New Hampshire
hospital critical time intervention is a
program that is used in other states
that start prior to the discharge from a
hospital and goes through nine months
and it is very uh the Fidelity to this
program is very important it is a step
down from right now we have act Services
which is a very high-intensity labor
intensive team approach to care CTI ey
is probably a step down from that it is
not as intense but it can be it can be
structured to meet any need of of a
client coming out of the hospital and
what I really love about this program is
it requires the community provider to
engage the patient and the hospital for
discharge from the hospital which which
we believe is very important to have a
warm handoff or a very smooth transition
of care so this program is going to be
um
really Central to a lot of what we're
doing this year we'll be recruiting for
uh CTI Specialists we will be doing
certification and training for our state
both uh state employees and our
community providers um very excited
about this program the developmental
disability system definitely had a lot
of focus in this review and really what
came out of this system uh this review
is the ability to structure our DD
waiver in a way that better matches a
person's needs to their services um and
and in doing that ensuring that we have
the full Continuum of Care here in New
Hampshire one of the things that that I
saw when I was at New Hampshire hospital
and even you know as commissioner is
that some of our clients that that
require the highest level of care the
Residential Care in a very structured
safe environment that that are on the DD
waiver end up needing to go out of state
for these services and it is uh my
opinion and and A&M agrees with me and I
think most of you would agree with me is
that taking a a patient that has natural
supports in the communities families
friends and moving them to another state
is not what's best for our citizens so
one of the things that we will be doing
around the DD system is really looking
at how we how we create eligibility and
structure the system so that we match
better what the needs are with the what
the services and then make sure we have
all the services in our state and then
one of the big uh projects that we have
going on at the department is mmis which
is our Medicaid system this has been um
on our docket and in our capital budget
now for years I would say several bium
that we need to invest in the
infrastructure of the mmis system we are
going to start incurring Federal
penalties if we don't get this system up
to date it is a very long transition
it's probably going to take 8 to 10
years from the time of starting to
procure it to all to having all of the
different uh modular systems in place so
starting starting that process of really
um honing in on the Mi mmis system and
getting it up to date and in compliance
with Federal Regulations is going to be
a focus
so that ends my overview of what you're
going to hear for the next several hours
so I want to stop there before Karen
takes over and just answer any questions
that uh any of the committee members may
have about the department or what we
do thank you so much uh this slide does
trigger a couple of questions it sounds
like under your new view of of how you
might change services in the D
area that there's going to be some
fairly uh Rich family counseling to make
sure that uh the needs of of the
disabled are met and what I'm curious
about is if there's going to be an
opportunity to coordinate with other
agents that you may be sending into the
field to do to handle other social
determinants of Health um so that we
don't have two three four different uh
client contact points when it would be
maybe more efficient to have one have
you uh have you have you is that a
problem now that we have many contact
points for
multiple uh social
determinants yes so it is a problem and
and I'm glad that that you asked this
question because what you're seeing here
is a precursor to exactly what you're
talking about which is full integration
of all of our service delivery lines
right what we want to be able to do is
provide whole family case management or
care coordination so if if we have a
vulnerable family that has someone on
the DD waiver someone with mental health
um mental illness uh you know a senior
uh someone involved with child uh dcyf
that we have a care coordinators that
can go in and take care of the entire
family instead of them having four or
five different touch points with the
Department that's where we're heading
the long-term vision is exactly what
you're talking about representative
Edwards that we're we're shooting for
and some of the things that we're doing
right now in for the next two years is
teeing that up to look at that that that
integrated model in the department um
the the journey to get to whole family
case management and care coordination uh
a health home home or some type of model
that allows us to take the whole family
as a unit versus several touch points is
a multi- banum project it is not it is
not it's not something that can be
accomplished in two years because part
part of the issue is that the department
has structured a lot of their programs
around Federal funding the federal the
federal government funds this part so we
develop a program to capture that
Federal funding um we need to change
that up but we do need to align the
federal programs with our state programs
so this is part of what we're doing to
get to exactly what you're talking about
okay so that leads into the mmis I I had
a trivia question of whether or not the
mpti index is going to be in there or
not but but probably the more
significant question is uh is is this
the Mi mmis going to um specifically be
tailored so it's featur teachers support
this integrated approach or are you
going to be fighting the information
system to help you do the care that you
want um I think that updating mmis is
going to help with the integration of
the department overall I think a
specific question to that end is
probably best directed at Dave leers who
will be on later in the program and talk
about mmis in detail about what we're
going to be doing okay that's that's
fair I I just want to leave you with the
idea that I I hope if we're going to
take 10 years to procure a system it
supports your vision of an integrated uh
family touch
point I think the the the best thing
about the way we're procuring mmis is
we're doing it in a modular fashion so
that when we when we change something in
our state we don't have to throw it the
whole system because it's done in
modulars we only have we would only have
to change one modular if we change even
if State Law changes or something like
that um and that is why one of the
reasons why we're doing this is that it
allows for those subtle changes to be
made without without needing to comp do
a complete overhaul of the entire
system great um are there any other
questions anyone so I I want to thank
you I want to let you know that if you
need some uh legislative support in your
transformation process that you're
seeing some roadblocks to keep you from
doing things smarter and making things
better for New Hampshire um you know
look at us as allies too and not just
the people trying to cut your
budget thank you appreciate
it all
right uh over to
Karen thank you so this slide here um is
really just a preview for what you're
going to see from uh lots of the
divisions um and just to hit some of
this on a high level as the commissioner
mentioned the Medicaid case loads are
higher because of the requirements to
receive the enhanced fmap um TANF
continues to stay steady uh we believe
that's partially due to the additional
unemployment benefits that are available
um yes representative
Edwards so be gentle with us with your
acronyms
like the first because because I think
you just stuck two of them in my eye
right there so sorry about that that's
all
right so
um TANF is uh temporary assistance for
needy families it's a program that Chris
santanello will explain in her
presentation um for the division of
Economic and housing stability um that
program like I mentioned has stayed
fairly steady um we believe because
partially because of the additional
unemployment benefits that are available
during the
pandemic um the same is true of
APD
um and I always forget what This Acronym
is so I'm sorry I do know I believe
Kevin provided the list of acronyms
which I'm sure are very overwhelming I
believe it's something like 40 pages of
acronyms that we use at our department
um so it is very overwhelming I do
understand
so that's aid for the permanently and
totally disabled thank you commissioner
I don't know why I always forget that
one I think we're going to have to form
the dark the department acronym
reduction
[Laughter]
committee um and snap which is otherwise
known as food stamps also um continues
on a dowbor trend for the last many
years part of that uh is related to if
you look look at 2017 to 2018 there was
an increase in tanif there was a change
in eligibility um during the legislative
session that increased the um benefit
and the number of people that are
eligible which also then decrease the
number of people eligible for
SNAP so like I mentioned uh Henry Litman
in Medicaid will certainly spend a lot
more time on the case loads for Medicaid
uh long-term care is what LTC is and Deb
sheets will cover more of that in Long
in her long-term supports and services
presentation and the last three Chris
santinello will cover in dehs which is
um I believe on Tuesday of next
week I wanted to talk to you a little
bit about budgeting those of you who
have been on the committee are familiar
with my diagram um this was something
that Mary kiss and I created when I came
on board to help un people understand
how things work for DHHS because for a
lot of agencies there's just budget and
actual and for our department there's
also something called C cost
allocation cost allocation is a
federally required uh mechanism we have
a um what is called a payap pacap which
is public assistance cost allocation
plan that is federally required to uh
determine how our expenditures are paid
throughout the department and each of
these three things uh intersect in
different ways budget to actual um that
typically the interaction there is that
there is some kind of lapse at the end
of the year um cost allocation to
actuals there are typically adjustments
so we may have budgeted it um one way
and then later on uh realize that the
earn is a little bit different and then
budget to cost allocation is how we are
doing our Revenue estimates and of
course the intersection of all that is
reporting uh just to give you a little
bit of an example from cost
allocation we have about 200 different
Revenue sources in the department um the
commissioner myself anyone at a senior
management level is paid by virtually
all of those 200 different sources so my
salary may be made up of you know $3 of
one type of program um but that is
required by the cost allocation
plan the briefing book that the chair
was speaking about earlier um I will
have that to you uh it looks like
tomorrow which is great um but this I
wanted to just give you a sense of what
you're going to see in this document you
you will see one of these charts here
for every accounting unit that is
greater than a million dollars um so
we'll give you the fiscal 20 actuals the
fiscal year 21 adjusted authorized uh
the agency request for 22 and 23 and the
governor budget for 22 and
23 each of the accounting uh units also
has a uh written information which
includes uh what I've listed there at
the bottom of the Slide the purpose the
client profile Financial summary which
is what is shown above funding sources
so um like I mentioned earlier you know
it lists that there are many funding
sources uh in the office of the
commissioner State mandates and federal
Mand mandates which goes back to what
you were asking about earlier chair
about um you know which missions are
required by law um you would see those
for those largest accounting units the
services that are provided how they're
provided and our expected
outcomes so it's quite a detailed book I
don't remember how many pages it is this
year I think somewhere around
200 yes representative Edwards thank you
I um uh Mr Ripple and I had been talking
in background about uh adding two prior
fiscal years to it 18 18 and 19 so that
there's a little bit more of a running
Trend um to to to give context to the
numbers to the right yes how how might
that happen will that happen or or or
not yes so uh it will not be in the
briefing book but what what I do have
for you and we I think we'll have that
done Tuesday if I remember correctly um
is I will have a spreadsheet for you an
Excel document I'll provide it in Excel
that has fiscal year 18 19 and 20
actuals fiscal year 21 budget or
adjusted authorized and then agency and
Governor excuse me just to give you a
heads up that is about
3,000 thank
you excuse
me so this is meant to just give you a
highlight sense of the budgets by
division and um again only has uh 21 22
23 uh the division names I did shorten
there just so that we could fit all of
the numbers on the
page excuse
me um so starting at uh the first one
there that's the division for Behavioral
Health um
the the budget here from the agency
phase to the governor's phase actually
increased there was a program um that
did not get budgeted in the agency phase
that was overlooked that the governor
kindly added um back into the
budget dcyf the uh the reduction you see
here is uh primarily due to um well the
overall reduction that you're seeing
from 163 million down to 136 million is
not a reduction to the dcyf budget we
moved the Medicaid expenditures so kids
who are in out of home placement that
qualify for Medicaid previously we put
those Medicaid expenditures in the dcyf
budget to um to put all of the Medicaid
expenditures together um made a lot more
sense so those expenditures are now
within the Medicaid budget so will see
that corresponding increase over in the
Medicaid budget um from that change yes
representative
Edwards so are you able to move your
mouse around to show us what cell you're
talking about at each yes I can do that
um yeah this 163 million to 136 million
here and the other thing I would mention
is this is meant to just be very high
level each of the divisions of course we
we'll de dive into all of these numbers
with you
[Music]
so this you know $30 million reduction
in the DCF budget is not truly a
reduction it is just moving the Medicaid
expenditures from the DCF budget to the
Medicaid budget which is down here so
you see there's actually about a $50
million increase and part of that
increase is the 30 million
moved the reduction from the agency
phase to the governor's phase
um was a reduction in funded positions
um there were about
20ish uh cpsw positions that were
unfunded um due to
vacancies economic and housing
stability um there's not a lot of change
in this budget there were some minor
changes that we can go over when we
review that budget
long-term supports and services this
includes U developmental disabilities as
well as uh long-term
care and um the changes here were
primarily to the developmental
disabilities budget and uh the director
will cover those in her presentation as
well this is the division uh of Medicaid
services
uh this is of course our largest
budget I would mention that this does
not include Medicaid expansion this is
only standard Medicaid as well as
several other accounting units related
to Medicaid uh as I mentioned one of the
largest increases was just moving those
dcyf expenditures from the dcyf budget
into the Medicaid budget um there were
also um expected changes in enrollment
um what I would mention there are two
uh anomalies if you will for fiscal year
22 in this budget we have been told to
expect the enhanced fmap to continue
through December of 21 so we have um
adjusted the federal General funds to
um to budget for what we expect will
happen there with receiving that
enhanced fmap for those two quarters of
fiscal year 22
um that also means that the case loads
will continue to stay high through those
first two quarters of fiscal year
22 otherwise this is budgeted as though
the case LS go back to a preco level as
of January 1 of
22 but again the Medicaid budget will go
into that in a lot more
depth um the division for Public Health
Services one of the the main changes
here from the agency phase in oop sorry
representative Edwards did I see your
hand no okay sorry um division of Public
Health Services one of the changes here
uh from the agency phase to the
governor's phase was in the um Family
Planning space there is an anticipated
rule change at the federal level where
previously um there were some Family
Planning facilities in the state that
could no longer receive federal funds
directly from the federal government and
last bym had been provided General funds
uh to make up for that it is anticipated
that the rules will change um and they
will receive those federal funds from
the federal government again so that was
a change made in the agency
budget during the governor's
phase Glen Cliff um continues to remain
steady in budgeting and there's really
no substantial changes in their
budget New Hampshire
hospital as I mentioned earlier the
largest increase there is the additional
positions to fully staff the uh Hospital
Wing that has been converted or will be
converted in process of being converted
from a children's Wing to an adult Wing
uh additionally the increase here is
also related to the path program which
is the transitional housing program that
we stood up this fall at the Philbrook
building and the last two of course are
Office of the commissioner the first one
being operations and the second one
being Bureau of Information Services
which you will hear from later
today so again that's just a high
overview and I would expect that you
will get a lot more details as we go
through each division it looks like you
got one more slide I
do okay um so just to mention a few of
the prioritized needs the governor's
budget uh was not able to include any of
the prioritized needs that we had and I
just wanted to mention there were some
prioritized needs for shelter funds and
homeless and housing uh tobacco
prevention program as well as many
deferred maintenance items to building
that DHHS um owns and maintains uh we
have all of our facilities like New
Hampshire hospital and Glen Cliff syc
which is sununu Youth Services Center
they all are owned and managed by the
department so there are deferred
maintenance items related to those um as
well as some operating costs for it
items which Dave weers can cover later
today um and Lori Weber will talk about
the Deferred maintenance
I just want to make sure I understand
what you just said this is these are
things that DHHS says are important but
the governor's budget did not fund
correct that's okay what how much money
does that represent and it is it all
operational money or is some of that
Capital NOP these are all operational um
and I don't remember the numbers off the
top of my head what I will make sure to
do is provide those to you
are there questions from the
committee representative Bean were you
just stretching your hand
there I'm good okay all
right okay uh very good what's your plan
now Mr Ripple go ahead if I may if there
are any other questions for the
commissioner I would just like to give
you all the opportunity to ask her those
now uh related to the department um as
she will probably jump off after this
and um Lori Weaver and I will be picking
up she's busy I I understand her need to
go and um I if we need to get hold of
her later I imagine she'll take a phone
call or an email
so yes email is is probably best way to
reach me as uh I'm not picking up my
voicemails as often as uh I I can
because I'm I'm up at the emergency
operation ation Center um at least half
of the week so um often not in my
office thank you appreciate it are there
any questions for the
commissioner all right I don't see
any thank you so
much so Mr
Ripple help me here um is this where
we're supposed to go through actual
spreadsheets and budget line items or
are we supposed to go to the next
speaker well I think at the moment
you'll go to the next speaker and
there's a division presentation that
Karen and a few other people will go
through and after that you'll start
going through the budget Pages for that
division so do I need to bring over a
few more people for this Karen yes I
believe if you could bring over Beth
Kelly and
Landry okay
um those would be the two for now okay
so we we've been going for an hour if
anyone needs to take a quick bio break
there's a transition here otherwise
we'll just keep on
going all
right all right I'm going to go ahead
and um turn things over to Lori just let
me know when you would like me to flip
slides morning everybody thank you Karen
my name is Lori Weaver I'm the Deputy
Commissioner of the department
operations is one of the primary uh
things that I deal with um every day uh
I think Ken if you flip to the next
slide I can set the contacts for this
deck and then I'll turn it over to you
for the finance wow
61 if you oh I'm sorry I'm I'm not on
mute I just looked at the 61 slides and
reacted sorry that's okay I said the
same thing when I finished the deck I
I'm sure every slide is exciting yes
well uh I'm gonna get rid of another
slide for you Karen if you can go to the
next slide um I think it would be more
specific so the way the prior deck that
um the commissioner just went over there
was a slide that's had colors on it and
it had the different chunks of the
department and primarily
we look at that not as an or chart but
of all the programs and services that
the department offers so that if anyone
from the outside uh not in the
department wants to say hey where can I
find Medicaid where can I find food
stamps um they would be able to look at
that so it's a way that we sort of
organize ourselves to make sense to the
general public because it's a large
department and it's complex with all of
the various components so you will be
hearing over the next couple couple of
week from divisions as Karen mentioned
we have economic and Housing Services
you have the division of children youth
and families and so on we also have our
administrative operations sort of get
lumped into what we call the office of
the commissioner or oom as it's uh
commonly referenced in the acronym world
uh but oom consists of the pieces that
you have here in this deck which we're
about to go over which is finan and our
contracts unit our human resource our
employee assistance program our
facilities and maintenance talks a
little bit about our district offices in
terms of how those uh services are laid
out our office of Health Equity and then
in addition you have your Bureau of
Information Services with Dave weeders
and you have um Meredith Telly loops
with a program quality and integrity as
well as legal services so that's sort of
the high level of the oom and how we
Clump together the the ones that I'm
about to speak to in this deck and
Karen's going to start our off with
finance and contracts are a little bit
smaller than um the the larger division
so we thought it would be easier more
palatable to be able to present it to
you in one deck um so even though
there's 61 slides representative Edwards
there are a couple of blank slides uh
which sort of separate out sections so
um the first section that we have is is
a high level overview of the finance and
contracts unit I'll turn it back over to
Karen
so
um what I wanted to mention and
represent chair you mentioned this
earlier that you had sent over a list of
questions that you wanted to make sure
that we answered um and we made sure to
incorporate those in our slides with um
a few exceptions and I wanted to walk
you through what some of those
exceptions are uh first of all
seccession planning Lori Weaver is going
to talk about secession planning at a
department level um a little bit later
in the slides um so we won't be covering
that in each of the um in each of the
presentations uh litigation will be
covered by Melissa St sier who is our
chief legal officer she will cover
litigation for the whole department so
again litigation will not be in each of
the presentations and then audits of the
department will be covered by U Meredith
too um and a little little bit by myself
uh later again when she presents um and
she will cover that for the whole
department Additionally you may see
slight variations in slides as some
things were more applicable than others
for example here um as I go through my
slides I'm talking about one accounting
unit that um has all of the account uh
accounting finance and uh procurement
contract staff in it um so it's a much
smaller accounting unit um and of course
our mission is fairly clear so from a um
introductory perspective there are
um there are two people who are key
people for me in finance and contracts
and then there are several people who
are um who are secondary key if you will
who will you will meet over the next
several weeks uh which reminds me Kevin
if you
bring Mary Kalise over as well because
there may be times that I need her and I
apologize veryy for not mentioning you
from the beginning so as I mentioned
earlier I have been CFO of DHHS for
about three years and I previously
worked for the Department of Revenue
Administration for about 10 years so you
will see that I often still have a keen
interest in revenues for the state Mary
Kalise is my Deputy CFO I do not operate
without this person she is a amazing she
has been with the department for 25
years there is not much about the
department that Mary does not know her
historical knowledge is critical for us
uh Nathan white is our director of
contracts he's been with the HHS for
about three years previously he worked
for the LBA and you will see later that
there are many accomplishments um that
he has since he has been working for the
Department I look at um our division of
finance broken into three groups but
technically we are two um there is
finance and there is contracts but
within our finance team there are two um
types of groups if you will there's what
I would call the expenditure group so
each division including office of
commissioner has a finance director or
what we sometimes refer to as a budget
team member in this case for office of
the commissioner that's Beth Kelly that
was the other person that I asked to be
brought over
so she manages the day-to-day finances
for the office of the
commissioner um the largest budget of
course is Medicaid but the largest
number of accounting units is public
health so we're very variable in what
our uh finances look like um and that
last box I should have deleted I
apologize that came from a template and
is not related to the division of
finance um the revenue reporting and
grants
management so a couple of years ago we
established a position to oversee all of
the revenue after an audit finding in
2019 that recommended that um
we've um we've not been able to
implement all of our plans around that
position uh due to covid and the hiring
freeze however we have budg a changed
how we have budgeted over the past two
years and the finance committee last
fanium heard a lot about this we now
budget by Revenue sources so there was a
time um back uh that Kevin will remember
very well when somebody would say could
you tell us where every tan of dollar is
budgeted and we would say no we can't um
which was not great and last bium was
the first time um that we were able to
provide that and Mary and I were both a
little bit sad that Neil Kirk was not
around for to present him that because
he had been asking for many many mums to
see exactly that and I do believe that I
asked representative Earth to tell him
about it um so that is was an exciting
change for us it has been a change in
how we do our work but it is going well
and we're going to continue to move um
to do
that this group is responsible for
filing more than 200 expenditure reports
every year with our federal partners and
they're also
um responsible for maintaining our
federally required Public Assistance
cost allocation plan which I mentioned
earlier a newer part of this team which
is also um really with the contracts
team but works very closely with our
Revenue team is Grants management um
they are working to establish policy and
procedure for Grants um all across DHHS
and this is actually an area that we
work very close mostly with merid of tan
and when you hear more about her
division you will understand why there
is so much relationship between grants
management and contracts and the work
that she
does our contracts division of course is
in charge of facilitating all of our uh
Contracting Services of which we have
many we typically have anywhere between
800 and 1,000 active contracts at any
given time during covid that uh almost
double
um so the Contracting work over the past
year um has been uh quite High I believe
Nathan testified yesterday to a senate
committee that um virtually all of his
staff have been working full-time
overtime for over a year with very
little vacation time um so it has been a
strain on that team they are also
organized in teams that are assigned to
each of the
divisions and as I just mention men the
volume has increased 113% since
2017 the largest increase due to co over
400 contracts um have been related to
co I have a question for you on that
slide yes um okay I I just want to make
sure I understand if you have uh I
assume you have lawyers in that group
and that uh when you guys do a contract
you are the Contracting Office that you
are the ones that obligate the state
legally to the contract that there isn't
some Contracting Office somewhere else
in the state you guys are you guys are
writing your
contract yes so there is um an attorney
that works within the contracts division
um that assists with anything that's
related to Legal work in addition uh
that team does also work closely with
Melissa St sier especially as it's been
relating to covid they also work with
the Attorney General's office the
Attorney General's office reviews um
many if not all of our contracts uh and
our larger
rfps um as far as who signs the contract
that's typically whoever the
commissioner uh designates to be
authorized to sign the contract which is
typically only division directors so the
contracts unit staff themselves do not
become the signatory on the contract um
it's typically the division director
that's the
signatory so if I ever got curious about
an RFP we've released or a contract
we've signed mind I I would contact Miss
Weaver I I would contact uh Mr Ripple
who would get to you how how how would
we do that so probably the best way is
to is to work through Kevin uh through
Mr Ripple um he would reach out to me
and I would work with Nathan white who's
the director of the contracts Division
and the division director who um who
manages that contract so it would it
would probably be more than one person
depending on the question
so the easiest way to save you from
having to reach out to three or four
people is to do that through
Kevin some of our accomplishments
um the
um the contracts division uh under
Nathan's Direction has improved their
process greatly they Institute a for
inter instituted a forecasting system
and fiscal year 21 um and they also
rolled out DocuSign during covid which
was um necessary because there were not
people to come sign the contracts in
person and also uh reduce the workload
incredibly um so initial data is he's
seeing a 53% reduction in cycle times
for the execution phase of the
Contracting P process and a 10%
reduction in cycle times for the entire
Contracting process which is quite
amazing and quite frankly the only
reason why that team has not
um or that why that team has been able
to survive through covid is because he
has managed to put efficiencies in place
to allow us to continue to work with the
same amount of people while increasing
the number of
contracts they also substantially
reduced the number of retroactive
contracts from July 18 to March 2020
you'll notice that that does say March
2020 because as soon as covid happened
virtually every covid contract is
retroactive so that has impacted the
retroactive percentage greatly however
we do expect that postco that rate will
continue to decline yes
representative so
um are we having to pay a premium for
these contracts because we had to go
retroactive or are they still coming in
at the the expected
costs I think that they've still been
coming in at the expected cost so having
been at the Emergency Operations Center
since uh March of last year um I was
part a lot part of a lot of those
discussions with the commissioner and
contractors and I believe that even
though we had to make decisions in a
matter of days sometimes hours that we
still worked really hard to make sure
that we were getting a reasonable rate
and not being taken advantage
of thank
you
um as we discussed yesterday or an hour
ago um we have changed the way we work
on the budget um to look at revenue and
complete monthly uh projections um and
our current project for the division is
rewriting our policies and procedures
and the last accomplishment I wanted to
mention is that uh we have created a
finance academy uh to create training
modules to ensure staff are onboarded
with basic information and we're working
on the future models which will ensure
knowledge transfer and that more than
one person can perform specific work or
seccession planning if you will so
that's an exciting project for
us one of the things that you asked for
is what would happen if the budget was
in increased 5% and what would happen if
it was decreased 5% so uh for starters
if it was increased 5% we do have eight
unfunded positions in the division of
finance so that would be my first
priority would be to fund those eight
positions um the second thing I would
look at would be additional software to
support the contracts process um there
is some software out there that could
make us even more efficient so that is
something that I would certainly look
for or look at um and then of course
additional positions because as you look
at our budget you will see that we are
mainly made up of positions um and what
would happen if the finance budget was
reduced we would have to reduce um the
number of positions that were
funded yes representative so so I would
be interested um not not urgently but
I'd be interested in this software to
support the contract process if we if if
we can work with with you to find ways
for you to gain
efficiencies uh I I would like to uh see
if we can support that sure what I will
do um is I will have Nathan white put
together um something for you on that
and send it over I'd be interested in
what features or functions we don't have
now that we would be obtaining with
different software sure yes I can
absolutely get that to
you so as I mentioned there uh in many
of the other presentations there are
additional slides but they were less
applicable to um my division so I did
not include them so the last slide you
will see in each section and when we get
to like division of Behavioral Health
this is at every Bureau is okay now here
oh I'm sorry this is actually positions
sorry I'm jumping ahead a couple of
slides this is positions so there are
144 positions in finance um what I would
mention is that the Finance teams at New
Hampshire hospital and Glen Cliffe both
report to the CFO of New Hampshire
hospital who is Joe kisy you will meet
him um the week after next he reports to
me as a dotted line because of course
their finances are still part of the
department and I am still responsible
for the finances of the entire
department um but those Finance staff
because of the nature of working in a
facility like a hospital they do report
to the CEO of the hospital and of
lliff this is to just get give you a
sense of the federal funds and general
funds you will see this slide in all of
the presentations 20 and 21 looks a
little funny and the reason for that
that green block is other funds and if
you um have been watching the press
conferences by the governor you have
heard that New Hampshire has been
helping the VA the uh US Veterans
Administration acquire um PPE which is
personal protective equipment although I
think everyone knows that acronym by now
thank you co um and so to uh do that the
department um both purchases as well as
receives the reimbursement from the VA
and we did that within the uh Finance
accounting unit it was just a good place
to put it we created a class line and
that is where those funds flow in and
out of and so that's why there's this
weird uh anomaly of other funds
otherwise you can see that our General
and federal funds are pretty steady um
from 18 to
2223 and here is what I was mentioning
this last slide um is where we will list
the accounting units related to the
section that we just reviewed um as well
as the budget book page which in this
case is 1162 which um representative
Earth will remember well is not the PDF
page but the page on the um budget book
um there's also the briefing book page
number on here which you will have
tomorrow so you'll be able to refer to
page 231 to see the detail on that
accounting unit so this is where I would
ask the question whether you would like
to um look at this accounting unit now
which I can actually pull up um and
screen share or if you would like to go
through more of the oon presentations
and then come back to look at the detail
Let's uh let's defer looking at the
detail until we can just go through it
okay so um from here I will go ahead and
um turn things over to Lori
Weaver thank you um Kevin may we bring
in people from I you say the other side
it makes me think of the dark side with
Star Wars can we bring in people from uh
the folks listed here Stacy Silva paa
booth and Dave clap sure thank
you as Kevin is doing that I could
probably get started uh with a couple of
things I I did want to just go back for
a second representative Edwards on your
comment about the software uh for the
contracts unit I would also recommend
that you ask that question to the
Department of administrative Services
who has budget Ed and been working on
procurement of a Statewide uh uh
procurement purchasing system um for All
State agencies um so they would be able
to advise you where that's at we have
been a part of that there's been a
challenge I think for us because our
department is so large and so complex
some of the things uh we had a little
bit of issues and Nathan has done a
phenomenal job of working around uh
while we wait for that system to get
things done so um I just just make a
note that there is more about that that
commissioner Arling house could could
address um Kevin do we have everybody
yes is Paula Booth oh there she you do
yes thank you um we're gonna start out
um with human resources and one of the
slides that Karen had mentioned that
what we decided to address on a more
Global level was succession planning um
and that I will address that in this
section um my name is Lori Weaver I've
been with the Department for about 24
years now currently Deputy Commissioner
I've had various roles within the
department in that time mostly all in
director leadership or associate
commissioner roles um during that time
Stacy Silver who's on the panel here as
well as our recent human uh Resources
Director our director of 20 one years
just retired last December uh great for
her and not so great for us but we found
Stacy Sila who has uh been with UNH uh
for 20 years as our HR Director so it
was a nice transition for Stacy to step
right in into our system and keep us
moving we have Paula Booth who is our
employee assistance uh program director
and we have Dave clap who's our
facilities director so as I go through
these pieces if there's any questions
that I can't answer I may ask them um to
jump in but I hopefully can answer them
um in terms of succession planning um
many of you are aware that we're we
operate in a unionized environment which
which provides some challenges for us
we're often told that we can't use the
word succession planning um because we
cannot Target people for jobs because we
have to post our jobs and give fair and
equal opportunity to all who certify for
any job that they apply for so we talk
more about our bench and building our
bench um and looking at how having
people that could apply for those
positions when key leadership and other
positions vacate or become vacant I will
tell you that our plan right now after
2020 is to try to fill those 765
positions we have been decimated by
covid with our Workforce uh we had a
hiring freeze that lasted nine months um
so when we have as many programs and
services that we have and we're down 760
uh positions it hurts uh it hurts a lot
so safc's got a heavy emphasis right now
now that the hiring freeze has been
lifted on recruitment get folks in the
door let's beef up our staff and then we
will focus to that retention strategy um
to obviously have people stay and grow
within the department so we have a
benefit I think because we're such a
large Department you could come in
virtually in any division maybe spend
some time there and then you could grow
and transition to another division so we
are retaining you as a department
employee but you're getting a skill set
maybe you're an adult on elderly
services worker or your child support
worker or your child uh welfare worker
or you work in finance for Ken round
um there's plenty of opportunities so
heavy heavy emphas emphasis on
professional development um not only uh
paying for classes when it's appropriate
but also providing our own internal
training programs yes representative
Edwards so miss Weaver I I um I'd like
to know how what you're thinking about
the onboarding of that many people in an
era of covid and social distancing I it
just seems to me that the traditional
ways in which large organizations have
brought people in and gotten them to
understand the the culture and who's who
and who they can trust and who their
peers are all of that is is out the
window now uh in a in a zoom world so
I'm just curious if we if we go on a
massive successful hiring Rampage how
are we really going to integrate those
people into your organization in a way
that's effective and doesn't cause
people to just get upset and leave yeah
it's a great question I'm glad you
brought it up it's what we've been
working on during this whole time of Co
from a human resource perspective is how
do we allow people to work remotely but
stay connected right that's that's been
the big challenge for us I will tell you
50% of our Workforce is Direct Care it
is those case workers out in the field
so our numbers are fairly good uh in
terms of um
we have a 20% vacancy rate overall but
in terms of our service areas we're
we're holding steady we've had to
recruit people during the time of covid
and it has been extremely challenging
we've had to change practices we've had
to take on safety measures and really
it's like a paradigm shift right
everything of the way that we have done
it H has changed so in terms of right
now our we're probably the probably one
of the state agencies that have the most
people actually coming to work with with
restrictions we do have a fair amount of
our Workforce working remotely we have
uh such an Innovative team at HR we had
our organizational development uh
administrator basically her Focus was
your job is to keep people integrated
during this time of covid how do you
teach people to be connected on Zoom how
do we onboard how do we Orient you'll
see when I go through some of these
slides I'll give you some numbers of how
many face-to-face orientations we have
before covid hit and then you'll see
everything after that had to be be
virtual how do we keep those people
connected so we are um finding extreme
innovative ways to do that I think as
the commissioner mentioned you know
things are winding down a little bit
with covid if we can get to a steady
state and folks are getting vaccinated
it is Our intention to find the balance
of who can stay working remotely and who
should be coming back in the office and
keeping those connections so it's a
day-to-day uh challenge that we're
working on right now um so I appreciate
that I appreciate the question um Karen
if you could um flip the
slide please Lorry actually just gave
you control you should be able to go to
the next oh I have
control oh that's awesome what do I do I
just click it oh yeah perfect great now
if I could just keep it to stay on one
slide hang on I don't know where I am
what
happened all right here we go
so for our mission of Human
Resources basically our human resource
looks to be a business partner with all
of our program areas to be able to help
them recruit and retain develop staff
grow staff be invested in staff and have
staff uh be satisfied and want to stay
in their in their jobs and grow with the
Department um our vision pretty much is
is sort of what I was just speaking to
is to be able to be transformative about
how we do our business one of the
challenges with state government is that
it's it's been sort of rigid and or
inflexible with some of our ability to
do things differently Co really forced
our hand on that and showed us that we
could do things differently and we could
still be as effective if not more
effective so that's going to be a big
Focus for us um moving
forward these are the key when we look
at HR we look at obviously we have
Recruitment and Retention we have our
payroll benefits piece we have our
organizational development training
which is really getting in and working
with work groups to become more
efficient and more effective at what
they do and obviously training our
Workforce Development how many positions
do we have do we have the right number
of positions are they in the right
area um and and growth as well as
employee relations you can't have a
large organization without um
continuously managing employee relations
they're in a circle format because each
informs the other so as we learn about
what kinds of issues employees may be
having we look at how can we help train
how do we train supervisors how do we
train staff to sort of uh mitigate what
those issues might be so this sort of
all work together um for the various
components um we have uh I think it was
3200 something 3,260 something positions
um that were was in the slide deck that
the commissioner was on that breaks out
to about our Workforce spread out over
11 offices throughout the state so
you'll see one through 11 that's what we
call our district offices so we have all
of our program services are offered
through that for catchment areas as well
as administrative Services as well we
also have the what we call the Sops
campus the State Office Park Campus
which is um up on Pleasant Street we
have a bunch of Office Buildings there
as well as Haan drive we have um our
public health is over at hazan drive and
we also have three 247 uh facilities
which is our Glen Cliff home uh senu
Center and hampsh hospital so are are
all of our 32 approximately 3200 staff
or are are spread out um in those
locations this I'm not going to go
through each line here but this will
give you an idea of the volume that our
HR experiences in terms of new hires and
transfers and training seats uh we have
a pretty robust uh supervisory uh
offerings where we have a certificate
program we have a training series we
have a round Round Table representative
Edwards that round table was uh in
response to co for a way to have
supervisors come together once a week
and talk about the challenges that they
were having in a facilitated training
environment it's been very very
successful and it's scheduled to
continue um we had about 12,000
applications um over the last year you
can imagine one unit processing that
many employee applications is quite a
bit um we established 122 positions of
oftentimes many of them are uh temporary
or permanent uh positions depending on
what the need is um on redesigned
onboarding to a virtual platform in
response to
covid and provided support to
2752 DHHS managers so quite a busy
Department um HR was instrumental in
uh not only helping us identify uh for
Co there was a call that went out from
Employment Security or from um the
governor's office in terms of volunteers
and this our HR helped coordinate who
are those folks going to be in in human
health and human resources that could
step up and help meet that need um as
well as help with all of the um
procurements that needed to happen in
terms of Staffing and a augmenting
staff um so there's a there's a list of
accomplishments here but I think even
just the first two boxes speak to the
volume that happens within our within
our HR
some challenges I think we've sort of
talked about them is that modality shift
for the new employee orientation and
shifting to that virtual platform um the
collection of documents when you're
hiring somebody new for covid was
challenging because we couldn't have
that face Toof face and how are we going
to do that uh our hiring process also uh
took a little bit of a change so I I'm
sure you're well aware that the
divisional personnel which sits at admin
Services is sort of the mothership for
all of the state agencies so they can
give us Direction and we have to follow
it so they actually change made a change
to the hiring process which actually
made it a little bit more challenging
for us to meet our goals so that's been
a challenge to try to meet those uh
requirements we're doing it but it's a
little hard um as well as uh working out
how do we figure it our Workforce that's
out there working tell work how do we
know they're productive what are the
what is their output on any given day
our services being delivered we spent a
lot of time working with hrn our program
to be able to document actions of our
staff and to be able to show that staff
were producing staff were staying
engaged um and staff we getting
trained so our key leadership Stacy
Silver who is on the line as our
director we have uh Heidi Jackson Ryan
who oversees our benefits and payroll
and that does include um our FMLA Family
Medical Leave Act um and and
accommodations Lorie spring is our
Workforce Development coordinator Rob
Barry does a lot with our Ada and
accommodations um and Virginia lever J
Virginia lever is our odts administrator
organizational development and Training
Services uh person and Erica Kelly Works
helps with recruitment so that's our
leadership team in
HR quick education question there uh as
I look at at at numbers is New
Hampshire's style that the bigger the
number the more senior they are or is it
the opposite where the lower the number
the more senior they
are when you're referencing number um
what like like administrator two would
an administrator two be more senior than
an administrative one or vice
versa yes so the classification is
assist so if you take the first two
right one would say oh assistant
administrator is that hired an
administrator to actually an
administrator 2 is higher than an
assistant administrator I believe so it
goes one two three and four there is a a
series for the administrator as there is
for supervisors and other positions all
right kind of like the military the
bigger your number the better got
it yeah and then if you don't have a
number I don't know what that means
but but these are our classified
positions here actually the director
here is an administrator for so that
does answer your
question uh moving on to some benchmarks
um
so in person 92 new hires in January and
February so that was before covid hit
and then after covid we had 394 new
hires that came through that we had to
find another way to do that
orientation um and I have helped assist
with some of those orientations uh via a
zoom platform in terms of wel welcoming
people to the department and connecting
them some to something larger that
they're not uh in person uh at so that
that has been a challenge but I think
we've done a pretty good job with it as
I mentioned we had the 12,000
applications now some of you may cringe
when you see this next one average 55
days to fill the position from posting
to hire right wow that's terrible how
can it take 55 days to hire somebody
well when you compare it to it was about
90 days before so there's Improvement um
that 50 5 days is often some of the
bureaucracy that goes with trying to
hire in state government in terms of
paperwork Shuffle and and different
components so we're constantly trying to
use a lean process to get that number
down and to get people on board quicker
um and we're not alone you'll find that
every state henc bces the same
Challenge and we trained 1,120 employees
um for last year in Co most of that was
virtual uh virtual training
which folks actually showed up for
because there was there was this uh
element of people wanting to stay
connected we want to stay connected with
our co-workers we want to stay connected
with our office we want to stay
connected with those that we serve um so
we saw people making a real effort to
make stay
connected um when we look at what would
we do if we had 5% more 5% less
obviously we would do more of uh
training and development we have some
initiatives that we would you know
consider consider launching but I think
going back to the theme you're going to
see a theme here when we talk about um
Information Services not only the
software systems but also the hardware
we're lacking in this area as well um we
don't have we have to rely
on uh the state system which is okay but
it doesn't meet all of our needs when
we're talking about HR metrics and so we
have to do some of our own calculating
of those metrics which um you know we
would be great if we had a database uh
software to be able to help us do that
and if we didn't have the 5% obviously
we'd have to look at a reduction in
force and less training and less
Services um and and delayed response on
some other things because we wouldn't
have a lot of staff I want to always
stay in the 5% more I get really worried
about the 5 per less but
um let's hope it doesn't happen we have
about 30 positions so if you think about
that picture of the state and I had all
of the areas where all staff are so
we've got a infrastructure support of
about 30 HR staff and various components
supporting that
Workforce I have a question on that
slide the one you just showed do you do
you know if there's um a national
Benchmark for for how many HR staff
there is needed for like every 100
employees are are you are you comparing
this to a benchmark or is this just sort
of what we we've thought we've needed
over over
time I'm gonna I'm going to do two
things I'm going to tell you what I know
and I'm going to ask Stacy to unmute and
ask her if she knows if there's a
natural Benchmark I can tell you that in
the 24 years that I've been here this
number has been between 30 and
35 um I haven't seen it I go above that
I have seen it dip below 28 in times of
reductions but Stacy I don't I don't
know if there's a ratio for Workforce uh
relative to HR
staff Kevin can she unmute herself or I
can okay thank you um thank you for the
question in the past we've always used
The Benchmark one HR professional for
every 100
employees um that has slightly shifted
over the years partly because we are
moving to a telework environment but
that has been The Benchmark previously
I'm happy to do some additional research
if you'd like to get an updated number
I I'd say you're going to have a lot of
places to put your energy I just I just
would I just like hearing that you all
are looking at external benchmarks and
and comparing yourself so that we we we
are rationally growing or or reducing so
thank
you thank you
Stacey I have no green in my budget
comparison I only have red and blue we
have General funds and we have very uh
little federal funds HR is PR primarily
uh Federal uh I mean General
funded and I think
that my accounting
unit so these would be the corresponding
numbers for the for the budget book and
for the briefing page and that that
wraps up the high level of Human
Resources if there are no questions I
can go on to the next group
I don't see any questions any anyone on
the committee have a question here all
right I'm not seeing any so go
forth great thank you uh so our next
program is from the office of the
Commissioners the employee assistance
program um this program basically was
born and grew up in the department of
health health and human services and I
am proud to say that we have Paula NATO
Booth as our director for the last she
just celebrated her
31 years Paul 35 okay right it was 31 35
years with the Department 35 years that
is wonderful so Paula has taken the
program from infy all the way up to
where it is today uh it serves the thing
about HHS um e sorry excuse me EAP is
that it actually sits in Health and
Human Services but it Services all of
the state agencies IT services the
judicial branch the governor office and
in some case um in the courts and in
some cases municipalities so we're
talking about a program that spans
pretty far and wide has a staff of
six so the this group would does EAP
traditionally um provides Counseling
Services sometimes short-term counseling
services for our staff right for our
employees um we often have unfortunately
have tragedies that occur you may
remember the motorcycle AC that happened
up in the North Country a couple of
years ago a lot of folks getting called
to that EAP was also called to that to
assist if there's an employee death in
the workplace and
unfortunately uh that does happen and
there have been quite a few in HHS over
the last couple of years Paula and her
team will come in and uh support the
team with grief counseling um there are
all kinds of issues that happen in the
workplace EAP will come in uh be able to
provide some short-term uh me meet some
needs and if it is required for more
they can refer out for a behavioral
health um referral as well so
well-utilized
program um these are the I got a little
bit ahead of myself this these are the
various components of it which is the
individual own counseling The Crisis
Intervention which is what I was
mentioning and they also do supervisory
and management consulting so often Paula
will be called in to work with various
leadership teams leaders and often times
Commissioners as well it's a resource
available to anyone in state government
that is uh part of the system it's a
cost allocated system so every agency
pays in a proportion based on their
Staffing um to receive the
services um over the last year they've
been very busy as you can man imagine
with covid in terms of providing
training and providing support uh the
Govern recently launched back in January
January of 2021 the respect and
stability in the workplace uh EAP was at
the table from its Inception that was
about a two-year project um it was
really uh beefing up the existing
program that we already had but Paulo's
team was a big part of that um and also
one of the neat accomplishments I think
that's on here is this last bullet is to
provide some peer support programs uh po
team is involved with not only HH just
but Department of Safety um for some
peer support groups and some things that
happen there to be able to have a
facilitator and work with uh the group
as well as a DCF we know that our case
workers face a lot of trauma uh see a
lot of trauma every day and there's an
opportunity to also take care of each
other through the peer support groups
and their their group helps with that so
some neat accomplishments over the year
um some challenges okay here it is again
lack of a contemporary data collection
system right so how do you improve
program without uh consistent data
telling us where we need to go so paa
and her team have some systems but
they're not where they need to be so we
are looking to try to be able to have
one platform um something like
Salesforce to be able to ex use an
existing platform where we could get
some data that would help uh Drive
future programming but that is a
challenge currently um Second Challenge
is just the lack of uh resources over
the time of covid you've probably been
reading in the papers that there are uh
counselors are booked solid they don't
have openings for months um so if PA's
team is going to hand off a referral
sometimes it's hard to find a behavioral
health provider to take that on and I
think providing services to a remote
Workforce was definitely a challenge
over this last year of staff that needed
the support but maybe could only do it
in in a like a tella Health capacity um
which is is not the same as being in
person yes represent
I just want to do a time check here um
We've Got U a lot of great slides ahead
of us uh do you have a projected time if
we don't interrupt you how long this
might
take and how fast I can
talk well I could probably get through
this uh through facilities and the next
15 minutes turn it over to Ann Landry
for the last piece maybe be done in the
next half an hour does that work okay I
would I would like to Target being done
by noon so that we can take a break at
noon um maybe to 40 yeah all right thank
you here we have the team I think what
I'll point out for time purposes here is
that we have a a lot of longevity from
our councellors in Paula and her team as
I mentioned Paula's been here uh for
State service of 35 years so we have a
really solid group of of counselors on
potin um some benchmarks that they were
working on in terms of uh time in covid
I think i' I've I've spoken to a lot of
these in terms of how do you effectively
communicate in in a telephonic kind of
not telephonic but a telework kind of
World um providing interventions uh and
and working with employees that are
currently in the workplace or having
issues um and the clear uh clinical peer
support that I've
mentioned so if we're looking at our
budget in terms of what where we looking
at we could always use more staff to
help the need is always there uh the
data management system is something we
would like to proc procure when we're
trying to do that now even without the
5% increase just to try to find a way to
to fix that system and then obviously
there would impact on decreased Services
if we had to make some
Cuts so we have six uh full-time staff
for all of the services that I mentioned
um and pretty much they are primarily uh
generally funded as well although there
are some other funds in
here lots of funds and
then Karen there's no briefing book page
number on this slide so we'll have to
get that updated for
you yes
so that concludes EAP if there aren any
questions I'll go on to
facilities I I had a question I it looks
like overall we're probably spending
about $75 per state employee on an EAP
is is if if my math is right do we have
a a benchmark for EAP to compare
ourselves to so we don't NE the way that
we do the cost structure for uh the
funding is actually it's a lot less than
that per person uh it's based on uh
number of full-time and part-time staff
that an agency has um as formula for it
I think we were down um Paula and Mary
kis is on the line correct me if I'm
wrong but I think we were between 25 and
$35 per
person
yes we offer because we offer that as
the state service representative I I
don't you know in terms of the
comparisons a lot of of other states
Outsource their AAP with a vendor that's
not necessarily in state so I think one
of the reasons why we can do it for Less
is because we offer it as a state
service may I make one comment please um
the other part of it too is because
they're within this closed system so to
speak we've been able to expand the
services that this program offers to all
three branches of government and so when
you want to compare Apple to Apples very
often an EAP program outside of the
state system would be a 1 1800 number
where somebody might call and get some
suggestions we are a Hands-On onsite
program that really has been able to
morph based on the culture within which
we go into so what we do at the prison
in Berlin is different than we would do
for the general court which is different
than what we would do for dcyf or State
Police so we've had the Good Fortune
because of the support of all the
agencies to really make this a model
program um for other eaps as
well thanks
Paula any other questions before we wrap
up
EAP okay let's move on to facilities
we're on 36 of 61 we're halfway halfway
there uh we have a uh a bureau here a a
facilities uh management that is put
together with our office services so
some of our uh inventory and purchasing
uh unit um basically this group for all
of those properties that I shared in the
slide is responsible for most of the
maintenance in that group our district
offices the landlords are responsible
for a lot of that maintenance but for
the Sops campus the Hazen campus and our
institutions um excuse me facility
oversees that which comes up to about 25
lease spaces about
2,225 560 Square ft of office space um
for approximately 1,100 staff of how
that breaks out so it's it's quite a bit
uh of property to oversee we have
obviously we have our facilities and
maintenance that I mentioned senu
service centers is about 150 acres with
13 buildings uh Glen Cliff is 70 Acres
with 2 buildings um and also who am I
missing New Hampshire hospital is right
here on campus um with one building but
with many needs um so our facilities
folks are out there working on a
multitude of facility issues as well as
designing new space you've often heard
about different initiatives of building
things um our facilities unit will work
on uh being a part of that team we also
have what we call facility coordinators
who are in these regions of the state
who are our logistical and fac facility
support of a link back to any um needs
that they may have so we have we have 11
district offices we have 3.5 facility
coordinators so we don't have enough
staff to cover every office they were
cut many years ago we have not been able
to get positions put back in the budget
um since they were cut although there is
a need couple of questions there yes who
would like to go first representative
Earth representative F you're you're
recognized
so I'm
guessing many of your folks are working
remote these days and I'm wondering
which means a lot of your buildings are
empty and I'm wondering if you've
considered as I think many other
companies have starting to consider
staying on that model going forward and
starting to reduce your actual physical
space and
leases yeah so just a couple things on
that um we actually do have staff in our
buildings our uh we have taken all of
our buildings and with the appropriate
uh social distancing measurements and
seats have determined what our capacity
would be so we do not have 100% remote
Workforce we probably reduced at least
50% um so we do have about half working
at home um that said one of the things
that we learned is that we could keep
some people at home so how do we reduce
our brick and mortar so we have
long-term leases with the district
offices so as as those start to come up
for Renewal we're looking at reducing
that footprint and finding a smaller
space absolutely um but we do I just
want to be clear our facilities uh
people have not been remote they have
been Frontline and center of cleaning uh
and having to be if there was any sort
of covid exposure or any needs so I I I
I just want to share that that um there
is a perception that all state employees
are remote and and they're they're not
and these guys have been our Frontline
Heroes go ahead can I follow up sure
I I didn't mean specifically the
facilities people I met the people in
the facilities yes I know I just was my
opportunity to share that too I agree
but your point well-being yes we are
trying to reduce our brick and Mort for
sure
yes representative ever did you have a
question or were you just recognizing
representative or uh I was just
recognizing him okay kind of goes with
the
territory and uh last thing on here is
just office services which is your basic
uh Fleet Management Logistics purchasing
inventory archiving and mail services so
all of those are in our facility
area so I was talking about this a
little bit we did have a lot happening
with covid setting up covid tracking
sites vaccination sites uh procurement
warehouse space where do we put all this
PPE we don't have enough warehouse space
facilities with Fronton Center and
helping us uh with that as well we uh
one of the biggest accomplishments is
the path program that's here on State
Office Park South uh that is
commissioner shanet was referring that
to that earlier where we increased our a
transitional program for psychiatric
adults coming out of New Hampshire
hospital being able to have a step down
here on campus into the fieldbook
building and facilities in about less
than four months was able to make that
happen they were able to remove the
tenant renovate the space ready it for
occupany and then get uh uh patients in
there so it was a huge accomplishment um
emergency repairs to Glen Cliffe and
senuna Center who Glen Cliff is pretty
self- sustaining um but they do have a
lot of needs when things Break um as
well as senu
Center um we replaced our automatic
mailing system which is the big uh was a
big deal it took a long time to get the
money to be able to replace that system
and we finally were able to do that last
year as well as the uh fuel delivery
system at the transportation garage so
they've been busy
similar uh way that we break it down in
terms of field the these are our offices
as I think you've seen this slide before
we have three and a half facility
coordinators for those 11
offices uh some challenges uh uh you're
going to hear this probably repeatedly
as we go through the budget process is
just funding we don't really are not
really funded uh I would say 100% ad
equally to complete not only the ongoing
maintenance projects but also our
capital projects maintenance projects as
well it's been um there's been a lot of
deferred maintenance and we're sort of
at a breaking point for some of our
buildings um some of our properties um
you know it's you know commissioner
Arling housee says is it a two bucket
leak or an eight bucket leak because if
it's a two bucket leak you might be able
to wait a little bit longer so we're
sort of in that um in that mode and the
Staffing is a challenge as well it's
been hard to recruit staff to work in
the time of Co for for cleaning as well
that's been a real
challenge so we had have uh our director
Dave break in again I'm sorry Miss
Weaver representative Earth had a
question thank you so I'm guessing that
a lot of this is related to covid and
therefore perhaps covid funding and I'm
wondering first of all is that true and
second of all do you have an idea of how
much of it was you're able to use Co
funding to affect some of these changes
which sound like they may benefit us in
the Long Haul as
well you mean the challenges for from
covid
uh no not specifically the challenges
from Co the changes you've made to your
processes your facilities basically
everything you just been talking about
it sounds like some of many of those are
covid related changes but at the same
time they were efficiency changes going
forward they could be efficiency chain
going forward and I'm just wondering how
much covid money that came in the state
was use is there is there way to know
how much it was used in that
way does that make sense or no
um I think I understand but I'm not
really I I don't want to answer in case
I don't understand your question um so
let's take tele medicine I mean it's a
bad example but it's something I could
sort of speak to so there's an EO for
tele medicine which has obviously been a
big benefit and the legislature we
looking at trying to turn that into a
statute so that that benefit can
continue going forward that's not
related to funding I understand but
you've got your department I'm guessing
has gotten the line share of all the co
funding that's come into the state and
it's not just from listening to you talk
it sounds like some of the things you've
been doing to improve efficiencies and
so forth have improved efficiencies but
they've also been specific to co because
you've had to make these adjustments
that are covid related I'm just wonder
if you have a sense of
how how much of the co funding was
applied in that manner to to the benefit
of the long term if you will yeah and I
you know and it's it's hard to say how
much of it was I know it wasn't all of
it I mean a lot of the covid went fun
funding went to stand up these temporary
sites whether for testing or vaccination
or or cleaning and then yes there were
things that we had to procure like the
um equipment to be able to do the Tork
right so or the software that goes with
that so that that went to it and the the
idea would be to sustain that long term
right that becomes a new business model
for us to use that's what you're talking
about yes yeah so I would I would say
you know maybe 50% or a little bit less
than that um for that but a lot of the
money did go out the doors while the
providers to help us meet the need for
the covid so there wasn't a whole lot
inhouse but I I think that said there's
a lot of what we're looking at now that
we can be doing it differently and more
efficiently and we want to keep moving
forward in that direction and not go
back to the way that it was right so
that is our our main mission and vision
moving
forward thank
you all right I'm keeping an eye on here
for the time um
so in terms of budget decreases and
increases a lot of the same things in
terms of the work wouldn't get done or
Staffing would be impacted um and
oftentimes when there's a decrease
people think let's just close the
district office well it makes it sounds
like it might make sense but obviously
that's a complicated thing but we are
looking at trying to not necessarily as
I said be in our B brick and mortar but
we're still servicing throughout the
state and not necessarily from one
location so when you think about all the
eligibility uh that is Citizens say need
help right they often would come into
our brick and mortar we found that they
could actually uh be calling in and
getting determined eligibility either
through the system or through a phone
call so we want if we can keep doing
that and we don't need to have the
building then that's what we're going to
keep doing so that speaks to what I was
talking about
before Oh we we'll always have somebody
that needs to come into a building don't
get me wrong um we will always have have
a need for some sense of brick and
mortar but not as big so this is our
current square footage this is the when
you look at all of the properties that
we have historically um I'm reminding
you that some of these leases are five
uh 10year leases um that's how we're
able to get a decent rate long-term
lease and then you can see the lease
expirations so as we move towards those
leases coming up we will look at and
Claremont is a really good example right
now State owns a Claremont building but
we're looking the downsize we found uh
appropriate space because we know we're
not going to be 100% uh in the building
some will be Tor so we'll be able to um
even though it's state owned we pay D
rent we pay them rent so we found
property that would be uh equivalent or
less to paying that so that that will be
our goal as we move
forward and Staffing we have um I went
through this before about 25 staff for
the maintenance and then three and a
half uh four for the district
offices and primarily General funds as
well any questions on the on the
facilities other
than
that not not today I I I might I might
want to talk to you later about renting
and buying and just more what you're
thinking long term but but not for the
this
budget okay sounds
good so I you're done with me now I'm
going to turn it over to uh Ann Landry
who is our associate commissioner and
she's going to talk about the office of
Health Equity which is the last
component to this presentation right
here thank you thanks Lori good
afternoon everyone thank you so much
Miss Weaver really appreciate that um
and and so so so miss Landry uh my kind
of one of my first questions here is I'm
looking at the term Equity showing up in
in healthc care documents everywhere is
is this a statutory name or did is this
like the old Refugee office what what
what what was this yes thank you
representative Edwards um I just before
we start would it be okay to bring in um
Barbara seber and Anella cusa from the
office of Health Equity join in part of
this presentation there online yes ma'am
I was just so excited to get
started no thank you um my name is an
Landry I'm associate commissioner for
population health and I've been with the
department for um about two years and
have about 20 years of experience in
healthc care and nonprofits and
education so this is the um former um
office it's the the name evolved over
the last two years um it is the office
office of minority health and minority
Refugee Health that started in
1999 um I believe about four years ago
the name um and Barbara can correct me
if I'm wrong in the name changed the
office of Health Equity to be more um
all-encompassing contemporary and
comprehensive of all the services that
we um
correct does that help answer your
question you answered it perfectly yes
thank you thank you sorry I'm sorry to
interrupt who were the two people I was
I'm bringing in as a
panelist here and anal CA okay here we
go sorry and Barbara is our director of
our state Refugee program and Anala um
overseas our communication Access
program so I don't do I
have I don't
control yep okay thank you and I believe
Beth Calli who's on the office of Health
Equity Finance director is already in
the room okay so the office of Health
Equity assures Equitable access to
effective quality dhjs programs and
services across all populations with a
specialized focus on racial ethnic
language gender and sexual minorities
and individuals with disabilities and I
promise I won't read the slides I just
really wanted to read this particular
sentence since it captures so much of
what we do um through the office of
Health Equity we facilitate
communication access across all dhh
programs and services for all of the
individuals needing interpretation um
translation both the clients we serve
and our staff we do a lot of Education
around um communication access and the
use of hearing assisted technology um
vision and speech AIDS we monitor
contract compliance with all of our
vendors to ensure that they are
following the federal civil rights law
requirements including the training
that's
necessary um when we assist refugees in
achieving the self-sufficiency at the
earliest date possible after their
arrival to the United
States um on the next Slide the next two
slides really capture these I'm gonna
probably wave my hand a couple of times
if uh sure of course if we could go back
this slide is okay so it it seems to me
like you have an interesting combination
of services that you provide here it
seems like you have a lot of direct
population touching of actual people and
then you have this legal compliance
function
also and I'm just so my my thought is
are those really are those really
compatible within one Department to have
s contractual civil rights compliance
function with um population Services
function well and I will um let Barbara
jump in as well given her time here in
this office and um perhaps Lori Weaver
might have um additional information but
I I do think it's appropriate in this
sense because the federal civil rights
law piece of it is really to ensure that
our any contract that we have across the
department is adhering to the ability to
provide access um for their clients they
serve so as we know we we have some
direct service programs that we contract
out a lot as well and we need to make
sure that everyone across the state has
Equitable access to the programs as far
as translation um interpretation Etc and
then we also have within our office we
do serve your right internal and
external so we ensure that our staff are
trained our staff are educated we we are
um creating equable opportunities um
across the board within our department
but then also to those that we directly
serve as well and I'll ask Barbara do
you have anything to add or um Anella as
well um I think it's I think you made
the point that it's compatible in that
um we're Ser we're serving primarily the
same group of clients or portions of the
same groups of
clients well so so I don't want to throw
you off because the whole budget is
built around this notion but maybe uh
Miss Weaver someday we could have a
conversation about whether the federal
civil rights law compliance function
since it monitors contractor compliance
whether that should go over with the
procurement and contracts group if that
would be a a more logical subject matter
alignment but but that that's not for
today because we are we're definitely
into the budget and everything is where
it's at now but I I just be would be
curious long term if if that if that's
really the right spot for it I will I
will add um representative Edwards I
appreciate that question because well it
is very much in partnership with the
contracts unit so I think you know
there's two pieces of it right there's a
day-to-day cont the programmatic aspects
of it as well as the responsibilities
that lie in the contract office so it's
very much in Partnership um with the
contracts unit um if that's
helpful um and if I can add
representative adwards Anella kushit
again um it really is referring to U the
title six the federal civil rights law
um Ada of 1990 and um rehab Act of 1973
all those have to be implemented in our
um communication access plan and in our
trainings and our staff needs to know
the civil rights in order to um
equitably serve uh population of New
Hampshire residents of New
Hampshire thank you okay so that's a
good clarification because I was
focusing on the first many words of that
description where it says monitors
contract compliance with federal civil
rights law requirements and you're
emphasizing appropriately the training
and self-attestation
checklist all right well so I have much
to learn thank you thank thank you thank
you
Anella so the next two slides um
summarize our our program so we have the
communication Access program which as
you can see it serves the limited
English proficient dab heart of hearing
blind visually impaired and speech
impaired
um they have direct responsibility for
the DS policy and systems and hearing
and oversight of the contracted vendors
which analogist mentioned and then of
course that really is connected to the
federal Sor law compliance we also are
part of the Statewide communication um
rapid response team which serves all New
Hampshire residents there's other
agencies involved in that but germano
Martino who is our communication
relations um officer serves on that and
we Le on to all the community and
service providers and um provide
response coordination you know due to
layoffs or closing of a business so very
actively involved in that
work um as we move to the next we have
the minority health program which is a
little bit of a legacy um name because
it encompasses much more than just
minority Health there's a lot of
training and technical assistance to
both staff and contractors and Community
stakeholders on culturally effective
organizations and the education around
enhanced ational class standards we
serve the racial ethnic language and
gender and sexual minorities and
individuals with disabilities through
program planning and partnership um and
we improve our own internal capacity at
DJs to ensure Equitable access to um
quality services to all individuals
there's a small piece of our program
that uh our office that does rep
repatriation um and that's it's not a
ton of um of work in our office but if
there is someone who needs to um come
back to the US into New Hampshire um
gero works there and then of course we
have the state Refugee program which
serves all the refugees within their
first five years um to the US in New
Hampshire that's a federal program um
each state has a state Refugee program
it's very very specific to the Federal
Regulations Barbara has been the
director of that program for quite a
while so I'm going to give her the
opportunity to to mention highlight any
of um any pieces you want to of that
program
Barbara okay um well we work work
primarily to help refugees achieve
self-sufficiency at the earliest date
possible after their arrival to the
United States so there are several
mandatory components of the program
including comprehensive health screening
which also occurs overseas um currently
people are quarantined 14 days for covid
but the bulk of our work um occurs in
the first 12 months of within of arrival
um and we we contract out to
um to the to agencies who help refugees
seek employment um we develop employment
opportunities for them we provide
English as a second language and case
management to help them integrate into
their communities within the first year
of arrival
thanks
par so this slide looks familiar to you
now um as Lori Weaver just highlighted
with our district offices this is really
our delivery system as well for our um
communication access encounters so you
can see the volume throughout the state
I'm not surprisingly concentrated more
into in the urban areas of where we've
served um the communication access needs
of our assistants I mean of our
residents and staff and this includes
inperson over the phone video as well as
captioning of real-time translation for
those of heart Healing Heart ad hearing
and then the map of course is our
district offices that you just
saw um this is a snapshot of the summary
of individuals served since 2015 with
our two main programs which are the
state Refugee program and the
communication Access program so you'll
see that there's about a thousand
residents um each year from the state
Refugee program and then you'll see the
total number of encounters I'm part of
the reduction in the state Refugee
program of those served has to do with
the federal um administrations um the
changes over the last years and there
was a reduction in the number of
refugees allowed to enter the US
Representative Edwards so so each of
these are annual numbers and because we
helped them for five years there's a a a
cumulative
uh also so so between 2015 and
2019 it's really more like um say
10,500 total in the population served is
that am I reading your graph
right I'm going to allow Barbara to I'm
gonna ask Barbara yeah this doesn't
represent the arrivals through the
program this represents service to
clients who are already in the United
States so we're allowed to serve people
within our federal regulations for up to
five years so this this represents that
last year we only resettled 48
individuals in New Hampshire oh okay I
didn't know how to interpret the number
whether it was the the total uh
population or or just an annual
population so thank you you're welcome
thank you Barbara for
clarifying
okay these are some of our key
accomplishments over the past couple of
years in the office of Health Equity I
don't want to read each bullet but you
really can see um the success rate in
what our state Refugee program is doing
in the first few as far as um the number
of undo refugees receiving Services um
the percentage that 89% of employable
refugees enter employment with average
hourly wage of
$12.93 100% are completing orientation
completing comprehensive health
screening are graduating from high
school um and moving on to higher
education in a lot of cases then you can
see that we've educated 387 Community
Partners um in the last year on uh
hearing assisted technology
communication access app so clearly a
need across our state um even more so
during this time of Co with remote um
everything being remote we've also are
um uh We've also provided 73 trainings
on equity and um cultural standards and
we've also partnered with Public Health
on a covid-19 equity task force that's
um comprised of uh about 50 community
community stakeholders as well as
developing an equity review tool um to
be used in
house some of our key challenges remain
the same over the last few years so data
um is nationally a challenge when it
comes to collecting race and ethnicity
data um I nationally there's a lot of
improvement as well as here in New
Hampshire we put a lot of effort on that
um the obviously the pandemic has
illuminated a lot of the disparities in
Health Equity and so even there we were
able to put um more resources behind
collecting this data and really helping
our internal and external Partners
understand how to better collect race
and ethy data so we can understand and
Analysis and analyze information better
there's also uncertainty um regarding
changes at the federal level with each
different change in administration how
that impacts our Target populations with
um the refugee program as Barbara was
mentioning and we're also in a
transition um right now with our
leadership our director of the last 10
years um resigned uh late last year and
so of course there's always an
opportunity and challenge with any new
leadership change but in the meantime we
are recruiting um for a new director
so um I know Lori touched on um
succession planning at a high level at
at the department but just looking at
our office specifically we do have four
vacant positions including the director
so that is something that we will ask
the director the new director to come in
to really look at how to um ensure that
we have coverage across all of our areas
and that we're growing our staff um it
it really the new leadership will
present an opportunity to evolve the
office's approach I mean a lot of what
we do is really dependent on the funding
that we receive um it's mostly Federal
funding as you'll see but of course um
there's an opportunity to be more
strategic um in our work as well as as
tactical delivery and so we'll be asking
our new director to kind of look at what
are other states doing in their office
of Health Equity uh yes so so somebody's
the interim director though who is that
so we don't have an in term director so
to speak I'm really serving in that role
um the office of Health Health Equity
falls under my portfolio anyway and so I
really have just stepped in um and have
been supporting the team um through uh
the absence of a director so I guess
it's essentially I am but we didn't
point someone
necessarily thank
you thank you for stepping up um and so
that's a little bit about where we are
we're in the process recruiting right
now and confident will will get get
someone in
shortly and just looking at you know
what what our outcomes how they would
change with a 5% increase or decrease in
funding um if we were to receive more
money we definitely increase the number
of internal and external Equity
trainings it's clearly very important
across our state we would allow for more
professional development opportunities
and conferences and self growth for our
staff and we' be able to expand
translation services as well should we
see a decrease we would unfortunately
decrease the number of clients served
with translation services we would have
to reduce the number of trainings on
equity and cultural linguistic standards
and we would um potentially inhibit our
ability to apply for and receive new
grants because of course we need
resources to do yes represent so on
translation services are those uh is the
scope of that related strictly to
containing uh Health Services or those
translation services expanded so that
they can go contract for an apartment or
they can interact properly at the Town
Hall how what what's the scope and the
boundary of the scope for translation
services thank you for that question I'm
actually gonna um ask Anella if she's
much better at giving um a summary of of
our scope here Anella are you still on
yes I am thanks in um so the translation
we work of the federal HHS rule um and
so we will translate all vital documents
into languages that meet 5% or 1,000
whichever is lower and So currently only
Spanish language meets that threshold
and we will translate all vital
documents across programs in the
department um if the staff is receiving
documents in another language in order
for them to process or do their job they
have to be able to access that document
we do translate those into English so
that we can do our jobs and then if the
decision has to be sent in the language
that family speaks we will then
translate our decisions into those
languages I hope that answer the
question uh very very very nearly uh I'm
just curious about the definition of a
vital document is it vital strictly in
the health care sense or vital to being
able to be an independent
adult for different programs it will be
whatever that program identifies as a
vital usually those are the consent
anything that person has to sign they
have to be able to understand what
they're signing application for
assistance um but it excludes things
like flyers and um brochures unless it's
um so so rights and responsibilities
will be a vital document but here's
helpful thing to know is not a vital
document thank
you again just a breakdown of our
recommended positions um across our
office we have eight in the minority
health and Refugee Affairs piece and
then three in the refugee
Services
Unit um a breakdown of our funding as
you can see we are primarily Federal
funded um with a little bit of General
funds and here are the references to the
budget book page numbers and the
briefing book page
numbers and that is it so I know I spoke
really fast to get us in before your
noon deadline there's a few minutes um
left if you have any other questions or
for for our office or for Karen or
anyone else
very nice job are are there questions
from the
committee yes representative
wer I have scheduled a pre fiscal at
3:30 you think we'll be wrapped up by
then so uh I was just going to go into
that um we're we're going to uh shift
things around a little bit we're going
to take a a break for about 15 20
minutes since most people are at home to
to just get their lunch and get ready to
start again
um we'll start back up by 12 1220 and
then we'll hit legal uh and we'll hit
legal top to bottom from from the
overview to the budget numbers because
um um Miss St sier has to be gone at two
two o'clock I think and then of the
briefings we've heard so far the high
level we'll go into the detail we're
going to
defer is until Monday um and what else
are we deferring are we deferring
anything else
Kevin yes it would be uh tpq which is
mer to lose right so so we're we're
we're we're shifting around and and I
think we're going to hit your 3:30
timeline is it you said 3:30
representative yes thank you yes sir
okay so I'm sorry just to clarify chair
you're suggesting that we'll go back to
the accounting units from this morning's
present
as well this
afternoon that's my that's that's my
plan I'd like to let legal go through
everything from top to bottom uh and
then so she can be excused and then and
then we'll start going accounting detail
of just the Departments we've already
heard the high level on today that's
something you can make a sandwich you
give me 20 minutes okay great if I could
just um just say uh Dave clap and Paula
uh please make sure that that you come
back um I would say around 2:00 1:30 um
when we'll be covering your accounting
units and the same thing with an and and
your team as
well so I I just have to say this is uh
the first time I've been in a real
Finance meeting and the first time I've
chaired a real committee so I appreciate
everyone's flexibility and willingness
to work with me I'm I'm trying to get my
sea legs a little bit so um so so thank
you uh and with that if there are no
questions uh
I am I supposed to take a motion to
recess till 1220 or do we just do it you
don't need one all right so uh it's now
1158 uh I'll see you in in 22 minutes
so let
us start the
slideshow which I don't remember that
there we
go so are we ready to begin is everyone
on
or we cannot see your slide presentation
though you
can't you can just see what your
desktop that's
strange nice looking desktop though nice
and
clean I'm an attorney I have to keep
things organized
um let me try that one more
time thinking you're going to say you
killed everything due to your data
retention
policy yeah can you see it now or yep
yes okay great how about
now yeah it's weird
though yeah it's weird on on on my
screen as well that's very strange it it
works so okay great so um thank you
everyone um for the record my name is
Melissa Saint Seer I'm the chief legal
officer for the Department of Health and
Human Services I've been with the
department for four years now um and I
oversee the office of legal and
Regulatory
services so on the agenda today it's
just going over our legal uh and
Regulatory Services some of the key
Services the case loads and then key
challenges that we have um in our
office so the purpose the overview of
legal and Regulatory Services is to
ensure that we adhere to uh we adhere to
and fairly apply our laws and
regulations um in implementing
legislative policy the five areas in
which uh the office oversees is the
Bureau of Licensing and certification uh
the legal Bureau our administrative
Appeals Unit our two EMB busman's
offices and legislative Services which
I'll get into a little bit
more so under our Bureau of Licensing
and certification we have child care
licensing Health Facilities
Administration Community residences and
our life safety um survey team so I'll
go through each of those our childcare
licensing team they do on-site
inspections at child care facilities
those could be um center-based they
could be family um based centers and
then they also could be residential um
care where children are placed from um
all residential for for res residential
reason for residential purposes for all
different reasons including um kids who
are um in the custody of DCF we also uh
review and inspect licensed uh exempt
providers and those are providers that
um receive federal funds but are not
subject to our State Licensing
regulations because they have three or
less children in their
care so we we review for Ing we ensure
compliance with state law uh also our
administrative rules we approve and
issue licenses um we do disciplinary
action and uh oversee we also oversee
summer and recreational camp licensing
that is a very new thing for us we just
took over um this year and it was a very
strange year as you can all imagine when
it came came to camps and Co so um so we
uh you know I've given you numbers uh
later on but they're a little they're a
little squishy right now because it's
unclear what a normal year would look
like when it comes to camp
licensing our health facilities
Administration team oversees the basic
standards for uh all Health Facilities
that are uh that operate in the state
those could be medical facilities
residential care facilities and then
non-residential Healthcare Providers
which I'll get into a little bit more
but that Health Facilities
Administration has the licensing unit
the certification unit and Community
residences and I'll explain that on the
next slide so Health Facilities
licensing is uh our State Licensing
rules and
regulations uh it's the licensing of of
all types of Health Facilities hospitals
walking clinics nursing homes substance
use disorder Residential Treatment
Centers ambulatory surgical centers
assisted living facilities and and
whatnot so they obviously have statutes
and rules that they have to comply to as
well we have we investigate complaints
we inspect them annually and we license
them accordingly and take disciplinary
action or enforcement action when
necessary our health facility
certification team is uh certification
for Medicare Medicaid so me uh our
nursing homes our hospitals all of those
who receive funding from the federal
government uh are required to be
certified and so our survey team here at
the department that's part of
certification oversees
and regulates based off of CMS
regulation not based off of state law
and Rule so their role is very specific
and it's um it's ferally
funded our next group under the Bureau
of Licensing is community residences
those residences care for
developmentally disabled acquired brain
disorder um and Behavioral Health um
diagnosis folks uh those Community
residences could have very small number
of of um of individuals which in which
they serve one or two and then they have
licensed homes which are four or more um
we don't have a a large number of
licensed homes most of our community
residences are small and there's
approximately 1,200 of those in the
state and they need to be certified they
get certified for funding under our
developmentally dis developmental
disability program so the certification
process is inspecting and ensuring that
it's complying with the rules and
regulations around state law and Rule um
but it's not it's it's less of a it is a
licensing function still but it is a
certification function as well when it
comes to the funding um to certify that
the residence is in compliance so that
it can receive funding for for um DD
acquir brain disorder and Behavioral
Health Life Safety in health facili
construction is ensuring that
facilities are in compliance with our
state fire code as well as uh
International building code they review
sprinkler systems um Ingress and egress
uh building code issues and ensure that
the heal the facility is built to the
proper uh code of the healthcare CH the
proper building code whether it's the
healthcare chapter or um Residential
Care ensuring that you know those
Sprinklers and whatever else is required
fired is is done accordingly we work
very closely with the fire Marshall's
off office in this um for for this part
of our
Bureau so that is it for health
facilities uh for the Bureau of
Licensing and certification our next
Bureau is legal services and um our
general counsel there's there's a lot
when it comes to our Legal Services as
you can imagine um with a department as
big as ours is we have an incredible
amount of legal matters we deal with on
a day-to-day basis and it talks about
here defending administrative decisions
litigating New Hampshire hospital
commitments U pursuing debt owed to the
state advising on internal and external
audits responding to lawsuits providing
legal advice and General Counsel on
matters within the department uh such as
developing implementing policies
interpreting state laws and rules
investigating and Advising on Personnel
concerns right to no requests contracts
and procurement hipa compliance
promulgating administrative rules
basically anything that our department
does and needs general counsel
for our DCF uh folks uh are the DCF
Council that protect that represent the
department to protect the safety and
well-being of of the children in dcf's
care and so they do litigating abuse and
neglect issues filed with the agency
filed by the agency to protect
children the DCF council is structur a
little bit differently within the
department they are a dotted line to me
under the office of legal and Regulatory
services but they really report um to
that's it's for funding purposes and
obviously relational purposes for for
our department but they report directly
to the Attorney General's office uh they
are
overseen by their legal decisions and
other things like that are overseen by
the Office of the Attorney General
our child support council is another big
area uh we have about 26 attorneys and
paral legals and other staff in our uh
child support Council they represent the
bureau um in state courts for
establishing paternity um and also the
establishment enforcement of child
support and Med medical support orders
so they do Interstate establishments
they respond to lawsuits against Bureau
they provide legal advice um and um also
general counsel for for the child
support
unit and our legislative Services um I I
I'm sure you all have worked with John
Williams in the past uh John is their
director of legislative
Services uh and all legislative services
are are um worked through the office of
legal and Regulatory services and a lot
of our attorneys are the legislative
lons that you see come and testify and
so they serve as a resource obviously
for the legislature in providing
testimony information on important
matters that are coming up in front of
the
legislature our administrative Appeals
Unit is next um we have a adjudicative
process for fair hearing for a lot of
applicants um they provide an objective
impartial review they get their power
their Authority from the commissioner
basically any final decision that's made
by the uh by the department can be
appealed through the administrative
Appeals Unit
there
are I mean dozens of different types of
cases I gave you a a brief description
of the most common types um that the
administrative Appeals Unit hears
long-term care child abuse and neglect
um APD or Aid to permanently totally
disabled our uh developmental disability
eligibility food stamps um just New
Hampshire hospital cases medical
assistant cases and prior authorization
for durable Medical equ in and
prescriptions so there's lots and lots
of uh different cases that they hear but
those are their most um prominent I
would say the things that they they see
the most
of and the AA is great because they're
able to see if there are um across the
department if we have um you
know if we have incidents of repeated
concerns or cases that come up uh they
can you know help the department
identify areas of
improvement our EMB budsman offices
there's two of them one of them is
strictly for clients it's to uh allow
clients to contact and have a um an an
autonomy I mean a um Anonymous excuse me
sort uh spot where they can call and
speak to somebody in the department and
and that EMB budman's office will help
them resolve and investigate matters um
and they'll track patterns of concerns
and complaints they'll analyze systems
issues as well but they serve as a
mediation they don't necessarily
represent the department they don't
represent um the client they they are
really there to kind of be that neutral
to see where the problem May lie and if
there's any way to resolve
it that's different than the office of
long-term Caren budsman where they
investigate complaints regarding our
nursing homes and assisted living
facilities that uh it could be quality
of Care Quality of Life um violations of
Resident rights and they are the
advocates for the long-term care
residents that their their role is to be
an advocate and to help them through uh
any kind of concerns or issues that
they're having in those long-term care
facilities so they provide consultation
and education um they certainly have
been uh vital in in our covid response
in assisting long-term care facilities
through through that process and so they
um there's only a handful of individuals
who are in that office but they're very
important so as for case loads I just
gave you some numbers here um how many
inspections we have done in each of our
bureaus for or each of our I should say
the LIC from licensing perspective so
childcare licensing 81 license and 22
license exempt facilities
um that's 46,000 childcare license uh
spots slots that are
available um they do about 240
complaints a
year Health Facilities they have
inspection certification of 1261
facilities they do about 3,000 concerns
or complaints a year um there's 1268
certified uh residences which I
Community residences which we spoke of
earlier 62 day programs and two Adult
Family Care Homes
as for our legal Bureau uh wring of
request we get 200 plus a year um our
state recoveries unit takes uh about $6
million in for debt recovery for the
Department we have a client Legal
Services that's set out by Statute that
is that takes uh complaints regarding
developmental disability qu brain
disorder and others there's about 300
complaints there year um Human Resources
the complaints we get from Human
Resources uh are administrative Appeals
Unit um that when they have to represent
our when our attorneys have to represent
the department in an administrative
appeal we have about 150 of those and
then we have rules and our appropriate
commitments and and about 80
guardianships as you see DCF they have
about
8 yes I think representative Edward has
a question yes absolutely I I just want
to recognize representative F who has
his hand up thank you
Melissa I'm just trying to map from your
presentation under the key Services all
these blue bars to the spreadsheet under
office under legal and Regulatory
Services activity and under that heading
there's seven things which match up with
your blue bars but there's a number of
other blue bars like for instance
administrative Appeals Unit legislative
Services child support councel do those
also mapped somewhere in the
spreadsheet you know what I'm asking no
I'm sorry I don't okay so um in the
budget there's Ops
95210 legal and Regulatory services and
underneath that there are subheadings
which which you list actually further on
in your slides um which I've already
looked at you know down to that what you
put the which you ought to put at the
beginning at the end but under your
regulatory Services you list six I six
accounting units there there's actually
the seventh which is your general
counsel but coming back to where you are
to your book bullets um that's only
seven of the like 12 things you went
through most everything else is is
within legal services in
5680 if there's not an accounting unit
specific for it so child care licensing
Health
Facilities um are separate Community
residences is separate Melissa um
operation support Administration I don't
know exactly the split between what's in
that and legal services Beth Kelly may
be able to answer that
and then of course EMB budsman and long
care udman are their own accounting
units representative Earth the other
thing is we're we're we're going to
immediately go into those accounting
details uh after the presentation of
this overview so I I I have I have a a
question for you under these child care
licensing do do you do this uh in a
combination of scheduled and reactive to
where you have a a plan to go out to to
look at them plus you respond to
complaints yes so we have uh every their
license is good for every three years uh
so they receive a a renewal inspection
once every three years they receive an
annual monitoring visit and that is
unannounced it's something that they
would uh we would go out and and see how
they're doing with compliance um and
then we would also go out if we received
a
complaint and then as a former privacy
officer I have to tell you Hippa is with
two A's not two PS it's a it's just one
of my pet peeves
absolutely um so going back to Legal
Bureau DCF uh currently 865 open child
protection cases um currently in the
State child support we have about 315
hearings a month and um Hippa which is
spelled incorrectly uh 66 incidents per
year that we have a HIPPA compliance
officer that uh oversees our
investigations around
Hippa and then our administrative
Appeals Unit about a th000 cases a year
our EMB budman's office has about 1274
cases a year and then office of
long-term care and budsman 320 cases
involving 531 different complaint codes
those codes are identified by federal
law um and then 669 facility and 132
individual consultant consultations when
somebody just calls to ask questions or
or um you know talk about processes or
whatnot so our active
litigation right now is we have
approximately 25 open active L
litigations um that are of significance
we have one Board of claims matter
um one contract an economic Tor matter
we have seven employment related actions
some are that that are pending with the
Human Rights
Commission uh we have nine personal
injury actions eight with dcyf and one
with YDC um and then we have seven
systems cases which could lead to um
costly systems and program uh concerns
and and improvements or or
changes so I've listed those here um the
first one is a is regarding our
development to disability um or Case
Management Services Under 171a um the
second Asar versus filber is the uh work
requirements for through our grant
Advantage program that's pending with
the US Supreme Court right now we have
two actions under uh our
IAS which is our involuntary emergency
admissions through our uh state mental
health system one is in federal district
court and then the other is in New
Hampshire Supreme Court both are related
uh we have one related to our St State
foster care system um and other matters
under dcyf we have another one price F
shenet which is uh for our our CFI
program and then carrian versus DHHS
which is a general DCF matter that's an
appeal um of of a matter that the
department um have has already um won on
a motion to dismiss but they appealed
and then then we have two settlements
that I just gave you General broad um we
have the amount that we had is
172,000 for employment settlements from
2019 to present and then uh personal
injury
1,792 500 and those are generally our
DCF cases but um could be other matters
as
well yes repres so so who does who does
legal report up through on the way to
the
commissioner so so the legal Bureau the
legal Bureau is under my oversight and
then I report directly to the
commissioner okay and then these seven
systems cases as earlier today uh Miss
Weaver was talking about TR
transformation and visioning and stuff
uh do you do you think that she looks at
these systems cases to help inform what
may need to be improved absolutely
absolutely we've take into account
anytime that we get any litigate
litigation U matter we always review the
matter see if there is something that
the department um needs to you know
improve upon if there's some some reason
why um we think that that they may have
gone to litigation and then we audit
that we analyze the problem um and we
and we incorporate any kind of solutions
into our in our plans going forward
absolutely that's absolutely a great
answer thank
you so our major challenges similar to
everyone else was obviously covid um a
large amount of staff turnover we had we
had a lot of individuals in both our
legal Bureau and our um and our Bureau
of Licensing and certification who were
close to retirement and Co um So Co
facilitated that retirement so we ended
up having more than than expected with
the hiring free it took a long time to
get people on boarded um for our health
facilities specifically we had seven
individuals leave and it takes about six
to nine months for our folks to become
CMS trained in our certification team
and because of that uh we still have a
limited number of individuals who can
who can conduct inspections because they
they these other seven individuals are
still in training so that has led to
some significant stress on our current
staff um obviously that and the fact
that they're going out and inspecting
facilities that they're required to go
into covid positive facilities every day
um you know obviously that's a stress So
Co has has certainly um has certainly
led to some additional stress that
wasn't wasn't there previously and then
our legal Bureau has been down as well
they they were running for most of Co
around General Council was running about
50% capacity so it was a difficult time
and and there's a lot of work to be done
so I would say that that's one of their
the biggest
stressors the administrative Appeals
Unit um our biggest concern and
challenge is equipment um with our our
appeals a lot of times they were done in
person at uh our main building and our
in in their office but now that clients
and everyone you know they certainly
don't want to come face to face we've
had to change our systems and have a lot
of things doing by doing video
conferencing a lot of changes to our
system and our equipment just isn't
isn't um Avail the equipment isn't up
toar to be able to accomplish all of
what needs to be accomplished with the
administrative Appeals Unit and then
legal our biggest concern uh overall is
is litigation cost and Personnel resour
Resources for discovery our litigation
hold um that creates a a huge burden on
the legal unit and the costs of the
department for the considerable time and
money that we have to spend on um
Discovery and litigation holds for the
for our um just toine litigation
hold so when a when um a matter is uh so
one of the current DC matters we receive
uh notice that they're that the they
going there's going to be a pending
lawsuit we're required to put
our all of our documents emails um
basically anything on hold so nothing
can be deleted uh and it all goes into
kind of like a cash a Bank where it sits
and just stays there uh to to then be
available for discovery for when the
litigation moves for forward when the
matter moves forward and so that's a
that's a very costly thing uh because we
need to obtain license es to be able to
get individuals on litigation H so that
their documents won't be destroyed
during the you know the pending matter
um until the until the suit is finalized
and so that's that's quite costly at
this point and we can certainly get you
those numbers if you ever want to see
them this is just a percentage of our Uh
current Staffing for legal and
Regulatory Services I know you've seen
the slide other in other places is and
then the remaining are our pie charts
which um Beth Kelly is the finance
person is on the line if you have any
questions around these pie
charts so you had um over 150 people on
the prior slide I'm just curious how
many of those are have to be attorneys
and and and do you need bar um those who
pass the bar must they pass the bar far
to work for the
department so our administrative Appeals
Unit and our um General Council and
anyone who goes to court all have to
have be barred within the state of New
Hampshire so that's most of most of the
individuals there are some uh obviously
legal services that are paral legals um
that are you know clerks and other types
of positions within that help the S the
units such is child support and and
DCF um but I would say a majority of
them need to be
barred and that so these are all pie
charts um comparisons and then these uh
the the overview of the pages and budget
books so other than that that is the end
of my presentation if you have any other
questions for
me does the committee have any questions
anyone so I I think what we'd like to do
next is um to go ahead and and all those
accounts that you've got listed there if
we could start getting into the
spreadsheet view of those so we're going
out of we're going in a slightly
different order and I don't know if you
need to remain for this um Miss Saint
sier or if Karen's gonna do it or okay
no she she definitely gets to stay um so
uh I did bring up on the screen the
chart that I did send over yesterday
that has all the accounting units for
oom and I figured I'd just walk through
quickly what the highlights are and then
we'll jump right into the legal
accounting units if that works for you
chair does thank
you great so the ones that we're going
to cover that are related to Melissa St
Sierra's area the legal accounting units
start at accounting unit
5143 so the page you want to turn to in
your budget book is
1,170 and we will cover all of the ones
highlighted in yellow right through to
longterm care un
budsman so I'm going to jump over and
I'll I'll give everyone a second if
that's okay just to yeah yeah do give us
a second because I'm I'm using the
spreadsheet um instead of the book uh
and I've not become faile at finding
stuff
yet so 5143 is called child care
licensing right yes sir all right Kevin
is Beth Kelly um brought
over I believe she is but let me
check she is a panelist she's currently
muted okay I'll ask her to unmute
I'm sorry great
okay so I'm gonna um I'm going to lead
us but quite frankly Beth um and Melissa
probably are going to be the ones
talking a lot more than I am because
Beth is the one that prepares these
budgets and works with Melissa on them
um so the first one is child care
licensing which Melissa walked through
what child care licensing
is um just to set things up uh of course
the expenditure are are listed here um
through to a total and then the amount
of Revenue is then listed down here and
the number of positions in this
accounting unit is at the bottom there
we are fortunate in that this accounting
unit is actually all on one page in many
cases accounting units are split between
Pages um in the budget book but
fortunately we started out with one that
makes it nice and easy all on one page
um so chair I'm not sure how you want to
go you can is there any way you can um
enlarge that a little bit my my eyes are
not quite good that's wonderful thank
you okay you're welcome um so chair I'm
not sure how you want to proceed if you
want to give everyone a few minutes to
look at it and then we'll take questions
um what makes the most sense for you
well okay so the reason I use the Excel
is because I just do a quick little
formula to see how much accounts are
going up
and I I I noticed in this one that the
general fund is going up
51% or about
$290,000 yes and I'm just looking for
the short story of of why sure so you're
actually going to see this in a lot of
the legal accounting units um one of the
things that we in changing how we
budgeted we realize that we have been
under budgeting General funds in the
legal area um because of cost allocation
so fortunate fortunately from an
accounting perspective not from an
operations perspective because there
have been vacancies there hasn't been a
shortfall of General funds in these
accounting units but we are now trying
to budget them um as they will be earned
which is a higher general fund
percentage due to that cost allocation
which is the Fally required system that
I spoke about earlier
you succeeded in confusing
me um so so Mr Ripple you want to
translate that since you since you know
my limitations what what what did we
just say about why General funds are
going up
51% you're muted sir I am muted there we
go um I'm not entirely sure how to
rephrase it sounds like um I have the
feeling I'm just going to be back the
same words Karen just said all over
again because I wasn't aware of this
issue prior to now is there is there
some feedback here yeah Beth Beth you
probably have to mute her computer tends
to get feedback oh right okay um I just
muted her there um so no I wasn't aware
of this issue prior to now but it sounds
like due to the way
um due to the way positions are are
funded it's a cost allocation issue
Karen mainly with positions am I am I
understanding that correctly yes and it
would relate to benefits and their
training because the cost allocation
would apply to to all of their
expenditures okay
so in 2021 and earlier this was not
budgeted correctly your in your view and
now it is budgeted correctly that's
correct yes so I don't know the details
of that I think it's something um if you
want to look at this further
representative we'd have to I'd have to
get further information on it he no let
me just ask a simple question then if
we're plusy up this account is there an
account somewhere else that we're
decrementing so that on net it's the
same but it's going to facilitate cost
allocation not necessarily um not
necessarily so by that you mean that
there is no redu uction somewhere else
to offset
this well our total our total budget is
an increase over fiscal year
21 now whether this is part of that
increase I I guess you could consider
that but there are certainly other areas
of the budget that have decreases in
general
funds but we don't look at it as like a
one for one like you know just because I
increased it here $200,000 doesn't mean
I looked to another area and said okay
now you need to decrease 200,000 we try
to make sure that we budget correctly
everywhere and then if we need to make
reductions then we look at that
globally and I also just want to point
out um quickly that we did also take on
camp licensing which was not in the
budget previously for 20 uh for 19 and
20 or 21 22 2021 excuse me so that is an
additional expense that childcare
licensing did not have prior to that
they do
now presentive walner do you have your
hand
up thank yes I do thank you um Karen I
wondered what other requirements around
um how much General funds do we do we
need to match the federal is there a
matching requirement or a maintenance of
effort
requirement on these lines
there likely is I could ask Beth to jump
in but yes I I think what you're
referring to is part part of how child
care licensing is paid for is with um
federal child care development funds
ccdf funds and so that is part of the
federal funds that are in this
accounting unit and that does have a
general fund matching requirement
ore Beth is there anything you want to
add there
be you're on mute
if I'm I'm good with that Karen
thanks so um so I would like to
understand this deeper but I don't want
to take more hearing time right now um
just just because of I I I I I think I
understand that we've had to pay people
previously but the we budgeted wrong so
it got fixed in a cost allocation effort
to move money from where we had it to
where we needed it and now we're just
trying to improve our budgeting but it
seems to me at the end of the day we're
still should be spending about the same
amount of money because in this example
there are 19 FTE in the permanent
classified throughout the period
um so so we're not actually increasing
the actual cost from a Personnel
perspective to this
department correct the total cost to
this area is is very similar it only
went up about
$40,000 um which if you look at the
benefits line that went up $70,000 so we
did make other reductions so that the
total budget um was more in line with
the previous year but the fund mix if
you will changed because of cost
allocation changes so do you mean a
different benefits line or the one
that's that's uh at 714 480 and the
governor's recommended yes is that the
benef okay yep
that's sorry go
ahead go
ahead I'm learning when you're talking
so
you talk okay yes the benefits line for
fiscal year 22 was is
677000 and for 23 is
74,000 those numbers are set by
Department of administrative Services
the same is true of Class 10 I think um
the reason that you're seeing a
reduction in class 10 from 994 th000 to
987 th000 uh and the same number of
positions is what Melissa spoke to
earlier that we had some retirements in
the this area so the people that retired
probably were at the top of their pay
scale so they were budgeted in 20 and 21
at the top of the pay scale when the
position is vacant it is then budgeted
at the um lowest level of the pay
scale so so just to be clear I'm really
concerned at the resourcing level not
the accounting level and and I think I
just asked you a bunch of questions that
drove you into accounting instead of
resourcing okay you know the distinction
I I didn't really mean to do that okay
so let let's go on to the next uh
Department unless are there any
questions on child care licensing
5143 before we go to the next
section all
right which section do you want to talk
about next so the next accounting unit
would be 5146
which is Health Facilities
Administration it's right there
okay all right I'm I'm I'm ready to hear
you okay I'm I'm certainly open to any
um questions that you might have on this
area the general fund changes here are
the same issue that we were just talking
about okay in this case General funds go
up
73%
yes and and like before there is no
change in FTE correct and the overall
budget actually went down in this
area because federal funds got backed
out
correct so that's not good what's going
on with the federal funds why did they
drop at
42% this this is the same issue that we
were just talking about it's about the
cost allocation so um the health
facilities back our health facilities
time trackers or are they something else
Ken um we have a change request in for
this accounting unit um it was key wrong
downtown so that's it's affecting the
federal and other funds okay the federal
funds to after this after the change
request is accepted or approved we
expect this to look um more like 22 it
was key R in 23 okay I see that it looks
like it's missing a million dollars yeah
yeah yep so representative walner has a
question you're
recognized thank you so I mean you just
you just things things come back you
know when you say certain words so um I
know that often in our budgets we have
had a lot of change
requests and I guess what I'm wondering
will we be getting a list of
those um sometime in the near
future yes so typically what I do is um
I will put together uh in the house phas
last time we had probably 20ish does
that sound right Kevin of things that we
needed to correct um I think at least
yeah there were quite a few so I I will
put together a preliminary list probably
mid next week that will probably only be
10 or 15 and then as we go through the
session I will probably have another
group um typically uh chair just for
your information what we submit um they
will have sort of two different tracks
there will be the ones that we Net Zero
so there's no impact to General funds
and then there may be some that we say
we made a budgeting mistake and there's
a an issue with General funds um as far
as requests for additional services or
different programs or or anything like
that those would all happen during the
budget presentations so we only use
change requests for budgeting mistakes
we don't use them to try to make
requests for new funding
know
so it looks to me like the the the
benefits and fringe benefits account for
the substantial part of any changes to
this budget yes and both of those are um
determined by the department of
administrative Services we don't have
control over those amounts
so are there any questions from the
committee on Health Facilities
Administration Mr chair I I have I have
one more question oh please ask just
okay it's more of a general question
again
um I guess as we since we are already
starting through this uh looking at the
pages one thing I would like to know
from the Department as we go through is
there anything
um as we come to pages is there anything
in House Bill
two that relates to any of these uh
budget pages okay is there um we only
have a draft of House Bill two we don't
have the final document but if there's
something in House Bill 2 that is
significant that we need to know that
affects Pages as we go through we should
um if you could bring that to our
attention
I will certainly do that I do not have a
copy of hb2 so as soon as I do have a
copy um I will be able to do that but to
my knowledge there's nothing that
affects uh this area or
or that makes me curious about your
process M RS are you are are are you
made aware of what's going into hb2 as
you're building the budget or is it a
surprise to you at the same time it is a
we make requests to to what we um need
in House Bill 2 um but ultimately that's
the governor's um it's the governor's
recommendation so there I would say that
I probably know about everything in it
but I don't know for sure what's in it
until I see the final published document
right so you make a request and and it's
probably going to be fulfilled but you
don't know until you see it correct it's
correct all
right I do have one more I do have one
more I'm sorry representative Wallner
please
ask okay I'm
sorry the other thing I'm wondering is
is as we go through these Page by
Page and we've started since we've
already started this process can you
also tell us of any items that you had
in your budget requests that were not
accepted and not included
yes I will do my best to make sure that
that happens as well okay thank you that
that would be hard right because you'd
have to you'd have to have a whole
another spreadsheet in your
head um yeah I probably have most of it
in my head to be honest yeah God I'll
forget a few things but but most of it
is
there and we also have those documents
available to
us we have those documents I just have I
would have to dig them out but we do
have them not in my head represent
that's for sure no not in my head either
I have to go find them so um okay so are
we going to talk about general counsel
next
5680 or what are you talking about next
yes 5680 general counsel and so to the
earlier question this is where most of
um everything that's not
um everything that's
not specified in another accounting unit
those are all pretty clearly labeled
what they are is here so when she when
Melissa spoke about John Williams John
Williams is in this accounting unit
here M the one that cut
down Melissa is also in this accounting
you're gonna make John cry I hope he's
not
listening ask a
question uh yes representative B so does
that include all of those bulleted items
that she had in that list of
key points yes the Appeals Unit is a
separate accounting unit um that's
labeled I forget what that's labeled
we'll get to it in a minute um but
everything else is here yes okay thank
you so so I have a question that covers
the previous area and this one just just
generally this agency income line how
how is this being used in these in the
health facilities and general
counsel Beth what is the agency income
in these
cases for um 5680 the majority of it is
the estate recovery fees and the county
estate recovery
Fe and then 5146 is the
um adult facilities licensing
fees are those um do they find their way
into your budget because uh that's in a
RSA somewhere or is that just obvious
practice they would have to be in rsas
to be restricted
revenues Kevin correct me if I'm wrong
but otherwise they would general fund
Revenue that's true if it's not in RSA
as a dedicated Revenue Source it
automatically goes to the general fund
so there must be a there must be a law
somewhere that directs that directs
these to the
agency so every time okay got it every
time I see an agency income there's an
RSA somewhere uh setting it
up there should be an RSA or a chap law
yes now these are these are not the same
thing as dedicated funds or are they
sometimes
no it's not the same as a dedicated fund
that's a revolving
account well I see what you see here is
a revolving fund that 003 that is would
be coming from a dedicated revolving
fund but agency income um is restricted
Revenue okay representative nordgren
question thank thank you representative
Edwards um we talked earlier about the
book that Health and Human Services will
be giving us that may or may not give us
some of this information um Karen do you
know when that we'll receive that book
you should have it tomorrow um Mary and
I are just putting the finishing touches
on it um believe it or not we're
actually ahead of schedule I looked to
two years ago and and we didn't provide
it till almost the end of February so um
hopefully you will have that in at least
electronically
tomorrow okay so mailing it to Handover
which takes a long time do we
know we we got I'm gonna to Kevin yeah
we'll I'm gonna have um copies printed
up and mailed out to you as soon as we
have it so uh if we have it by tomorrow
morning then prob well if we have it by
tomorrow then probably by Monday they'll
go out in the
mail okay
thanks are there any other questions on
General Council it's going from 84 to 82
FTE is is is
that why it's not a lot but why they
were likely transferred somewhere else
but I'll let Beth speak to
that and it'll always take be a minute
to to answer as she's pulling up
information plus that mute button can be
hard to
find sorry about that I actually am
looking up information can I get back
with you in a couple seconds sure sure
it's it's not a material question uh I'm
just curious I got curious so so what
are we G to do next M RS which which all
right the next one is community
residences
this is not a lot of money relative to
other things oh is it it is not it is
mostly just staff and support for the
staff so are there any questions about
Community
residences all right seeing none I think
we're ready to go to the next one all
right the next one starts at the bottom
of this page it's
5683 which is Operation support
Administration which is the Appeals Unit
so this just has class 10 on this page
so I'm going to go ahead and go to the
next
page okay so this is going up
48% and what's driving this people it's
not the people number Chang and is this
at the same cost
allocation explanation the total budget
is is the benefits that's driving it up
and the general fund change is the cost
allocation employee training goes up but
that's okay and then federal funds
dropped
12% is is this that is that that's also
the cost allocation issue
I'm sorry I missed the beginning part of
your I'm noticing that the federal funds
dropped
12% yes that's the change in the cost
allocation all
right and I keep asking that because if
we've if we've done something to where
we're no longer eligible because of a
decision we've made or a mistake we've
made I I I'd like to know about those
those are probably pretty rare I imagine
we try to keep them pretty rare yes they
they do occasionally happen um you will
hear when uh Meredith tus uh presents
about audit findings and occasionally we
do have times where we are penalized for
for different issues with audits but um
this is not one of those scenarios
thankfully are there any questions from
anyone on operation support
Administration I'm seeing none is on
budsman next
it is 56.96 on page I love it when a
plan comes
together me too on page
1175 and this this represents what I was
speaking about earlier about cost
allocation and how sometimes it can be
very low dollars in this case the cost
allocation um has $7 for for this agent
the income so those are the types of
scenarios where occasionally there are
very low numbers but we're trying to
cost allocate
appropriately that's extremely
precise you should see your cost
allocation system Kevin has seen it it
is it is quite complicated and uh very
precise okay so this is not a lot of
money is there anything else interesting
going on in here like uh we've got some
personal services
uh going up are we are we converting a
temporary to a permanent or something in
here I don't think so because the num
the total number of positions didn't go
up um those numbers again are are
dictated To Us by Das but I'm not sure
if Beth might know why that one went up
so much although it looks like the
actuals in fiscal year 20 were actually
higher than what we have budgeted in 21
so it could be that somebody was hired
at a higher step
um but Beth do you know the exact
reason that's okay are there any other
questions from anyone on on um the
Ombudsman I don't I don't want to hurry
it
but should keep moving if um all right
so long-term care on budsman next this
is really great it's like somebody built
a spreadsheet
right okay so we see a drop in the
general fund of 7% here it's not a huge
amount of money but is this one of the
donors for the cost allocation maybe I I
guess you could look at it that way but
yes this would be a change because of
cost
allocation we also reduced the overall
budget here so that's part of it as
well what what what allowed you to
change the overall budget it looks like
there was some money budgeted for
contracts for program services that um
that's no longer being budgeted it must
no longer be needed I don't know if
Melissa you have any history on
that no I don't I think that the um
travel reimbursement is also
down the our instate travel
reimbursement was at
38,000 fiscal year 21 it's going down to
30 right we also reduceed the the travel
in state and out of state
travel that was something that you'll
see across the entire department as I
redu I asked that every area take a look
at their current expenses and their in
and out of state travel um and their
contracts and and look for ways that
they could reduce those sure I imagine
you guys have some fairly tight um
administrative procedures to control out
ofate travel at this point the deputy
commit well first of all out ofate
travel right now has to be approved by
the governor um so we do very little out
ofate travel right now as a department
except for when required when servicing
clients um but even in non- times of of
out State travel needing to be uh
approved by the governor all out ofate
travel is uh approved by the Deputy
Commissioner so um are there any other
questions from anyone on the committee
long-term care
Ombudsman so if I remember correctly oh
then there's just the totals for legal
and Regulatory services so that's the
last accounting unit and in Melissa's
area Okay so so these this page isn't
would not be reflected in my spreadsheet
that I'm looking at right this last page
that has all of the totals I don't think
I don't know I don't know it wouldn't
make sense for it to be in
there all right well so so thank you
um so are there any questions from
anyone on the committee about anything
we've just covered in the legal
area because I I think uh I think Miss
SA SE it is getting ready to take
off she's got a two o'clock and you're
going to get there early yes thank
you thank you everyone for your time
please reach out if you do need anything
or anything comes up yes ma'am thank
you okay so I wasn't sure chair if you
would like to now go back to the
accounting units that Lori Weaver and I
presented that'd be great she's here too
she is she also does have to leave at 2
o00 but her uh staff will be able to
stay on so we will be able to answer any
questions so we're gonna start I
actually have to leave at 1:45 for the
two o'clock so sorry my uh my staff are
planning on being on it too based on
before we broke what we said let me see
if I can get them to come a little
earlier
okay so which number are we going to
look at for with her uh the 1159 no the
5,000
yes the accounting unit 5000
1159 and this is one of those accounting
units that starts on one page and goes
on to the next so I um blow this up as
you did the other
ones yep sorry I thought I left it
zoomed in
there we go oops so this accounting unit
um has the first two class lines here at
the bottom of this page so I'm going to
go ahead and go to the next page where
the majority of the accounting unit
is so this is the commissioner's office
this is where the commissioner and the
Deputy Commissioner and the associate
commissioner positions are so most of
these um as you can see going back to
that previous page a lot of the salary
and benefits are actually in an
unclassified um class line not a
classified class
line um also within this area would be
our
um
uh Pio office um so our
[Music]
um Communications office is within this
accounting unit sorry Shar going to jump
in but thank you I'm like why can I not
think of the word please go ahead public
information office yes thank
you I struggle with the acronyms too Mr
chair so Karen does this also have HR
and EAP and facilities in it or just HR
and EAP uh nope EAP and HR have their
own accounting
units so the only thing on the salaries
is that it's not just the positions you
mentioned I think there's a bulk of the
unclassified positions that are budgeted
out of oom not solely but there's a big
chunk there so when we look at that
figure it is in four or five positions
we have about 88 unclassified positions
um and most of them come out of
oom only 10 of them are in this
accounting unit though okay I knew you'd
know the exact number
I what what would you is I don't would
you like me to answer questions on this
Karen or yeah I'm not sure if there are
any questions
okay well okay so if the committee has
questions we'll do that U but I'm still
just trying to find it on my spreadsheet
and that's not your problem that's
mine um that's because there's probably
a lot of 5,000 well there's a lot of
5000s and would you believe it we have
more than one commissioner
how about
that yes so we'll wait a minute and I
know that um Deputy Commissioner Weaver
is also working to get her they're on
they're on now okay great so we've got I
don't know if Kevin can bring them over
uh Paula Booth uh Stacy Silva and Dave
clap what page number are you on Karen
in your
document uh we are on 1160
Beth while um the chair is looking um
for the accounting unit did you find an
answer to those two positions that moved
out of
legal I did um there were two positions
that were
originally budgeted in child support
legal but it was determined that they
should be mov to child support program
so they were taken out of there and
moved to
4270 great thank
you I know representative Earth was just
waiting to hear that we moved positions
I know he was waiting for that
answer sorry that's going to be our
running joke sir
all right I found
it were you able to find it y okay so
this is one where the general
funds went up
45% um by a little over 600,000 on
average and yeah I wanted to ask about
the indirect costs what what what
the indirect costs go up I think
124% and basically double in the 390,000
growth that's actually material so so
what's going on with that sure that um
that number I believe is also set by
administrative services but Beth do you
want to provide some background on
that now that's exactly right um Daz
gives us a for formula to use based on
um is that the salaries is that the one
they just give us a flat Fe they just
give us a number
um that um they're expecting to bill us
over the next year and that's what we
budget okay so but this more than double
so it makes me wonder Department wide
what's going on with indirect costs if
you got
smooth or if it just went up a
lot
um I I believe in the past we may have
spread the cost across more accounting
units I'd be happy to look into that um
but it is a number that we're provided
and required to budget Mr chairman go
ahead I remember something from the
Governor's budget briefing from Charlie
Arling house adding a new cost I think
it was either adding the cleaning cost
to the rent or some cost he hadn't added
to the rent before so we may see it in
every line from what I yes sir I I was
just noting though that it it was
doubling from the previous year from 316
to 7006 on
average so it's it's a it's big it's
that's a lot of cleaning but maybe
there's a lot of cleaning I don't know
well and it does look like in fiscal 21
that it was under budgeted because our
actuals in 20 were 500,000 and it's
budgeted at 130 in
21 I did take the average of those two
for my simple little formula but but
you're have to look and see if it's in
every line or if it's just mainly in the
commission's
line that went up that much in indirect
all right so um so you've got one more
unclassified
position one it now remind me
unclassified means that uh they're
they're they have pens essentially have
a negotiated salary or or what what's
the distinction between unclassified
positions and permanent
classified Lori Weaver do you want to
answer that so the r unclassified
positions are unrepresented positions so
they're not uh part of the union and
they have a different uh salary schedule
so they're on a letter system not a
labor grade system um that applies for
All State agencies in that L letter
grade I think there's it goes a through
P I think and then there's seven steps
within each of those letter grades so
the salaries um are supposed to start uh
at one and if it's start hire you have
to ask permission from
D so so who is being hired here what
what job
description there's it's a new one a new
job description in the commissioner's
office we didn't create a new position
it it was moved from somewhere else we
cannot create um unclassified positions
the legislature creates
them so we could let you know which
position moved
well if it you know we're going to ask
you so many questions don't don't chase
that one down just because uh if it if
it's not really an addition and it's
just a a move it's less
interesting yeah no there it's unlikely
that we're going to see well we won't
see any additions other than those
conversions which are mostly in New
Hampshire hospital um and those would
all be classified
positions so does anyone have any
questions about the off Office of the
commissioner from the committee as a
result of
the pmic okay so I think we're ready to
go to your next
area EX order the next accounting unit
is 5025 which is the employee assistance
program or EAP for
short 5025
okay so I'm
there and this only goes up of 3%
overall yes and this is actually one of
those areas that the general funds are
down from fiscal year 21 from a cost
allocation change so we got a an a
little bit of a kicker from the federal
funds is that an allocation issue or did
we get a new Grant no it's an allocation
change
okay I'm good here does anyone have any
questions seeing
none okay the next accounting unit is
the one near and dear to my heart which
is 5676 office of business operations
this is uh finance and uh procurement um
a couple of things that I would just
mention here the Telecommunications line
those are not just the phones for for my
staff those are the desk phones of the
entire department so when you see
telecommunications and other budgets
it's for cell phones this is just for
the desk phones uh we did that last bium
and it was very successful and worked a
lot better and because of that we also
did something similar in class line 22
you see that go from 3,000 up to 200
140,000 um we have we are now going to
pay for all of the copiers for the
Department out of our accounting unit um
so they're not budgeted anywhere else so
we there are just a few not gonna just
create another cost allocation problem
Maria it doesn't because those would
have been cost allocated um likely
across the department already we were
just making different areas pay for them
and it was creating more admin
administrative work than needed to be so
we just put them all in one all all here
under um
Finance so then there's a very slight
increase in
Personnel we did um the governor's uh we
requested in the agency phase and the
governor um did approve funding some
positions that have previously been
unfunded that were unfunded in 20 and 21
and agreed to leave some of those funded
in 22 and 23 we still do have many
unfunded positions but we have funded a
couple
more what are the couple do you know off
hand I don't know them off the top of my
head I think at least one was a
contracts
position
um I think one was a Medicaid position
Medicaid finance a cost allocation
Finance position
I don't know the ex have to cost
allocate the cost allocation position we
do we
do
yes are there any questions on business
operations and I'm just going to go down
to the second page just to mention that
this is where you see that other funds
that I mentioned in the presentation
that's 17 million that's the um cost
associated with
uh the Veterans Administration
I think it also is um and Beth correct
me if I'm wrong but the face masks that
are being sold at the liquor stores is
also represented there as well I think
which is the that number on my on my
spreadsheet um do you know what line
that might be class line 103
so I'm not sure if your spreadsheet
has oh I see it I see 17 million in
fy20 yes but I'm not seeing anything in
the out
Years nope because well fiscal year 21
is just the adjusted authorized budget
which at that time we had not adjusted
the budget yet for um when this was
loaded in August we had not yet added
the funds for the VA um transaction that
we've done this year in fiscal year 21
and I hope that by fiscal year 22 the VA
will will be able to procure their own
PPE
okay that is my
hope well good the veterans thank you
for and the governor for
helping you're welcome are there any
questions for on office of business
operations
okay the next accounting unit is
8137 which is workman's
compensation uh this is workman's comp
across the department with the exception
of the facilities we did keep the
facilities workman's comp within the
facilities budget because of the unique
nature of the workman's comp that
generally happens in the facilities we
wanted to keep that with them um but the
workman's comp for the rest of the
department is is here in
8137 and that's what the slight increase
is a couple of areas did budget their
own workman's comp and we put it all
into one accounting unit so is that why
it goes up 41% because it's just got
more accounting units this time around
exactly there was a couple of areas that
would do like a you know a $30,000
workman's comp budget and we decided
that that was more administrative work
than was
necessary questions about workerman comp
all right let's
go and then uh 8584 is
unemployment that's pretty much level
funded uh with level funded to the
actuals in fiscal year um 20 it it is
higher than what was budgeted in fiscal
year 21
okay so it's budgeted at the fy20 actual
instead of the fy21 budget correct all
right okay um the next one is
7208 which is minority health and
Refugee Affairs which you heard about
this
morning say that number again 72
7208 Karen I don't think we have Ann I
think she's still on the other side oh
Kevin can you bring Ann
over federal funds are dropping here but
we're expecting an increase in clients
are we not
Beth can you speak I don't know that
Beth can speak to the increase in
clients but Beth can you speak to the
the general fund Federal fund split here
I can because um
the um language Bank
contract came into o from
BFA so on a whole it used to be that
Health Equity would have had a higher
Federal fund fund ratio but due to the
language Bank having more General
funds than federal funds it's going to
affect the overall
total okay but overall the Department's
getting the same amount of federal funds
it's just being put into different
accounts is that
right
yes yes
yes okay and then we we draw every
Federal fund we can I can sure you of
that our general
fund is going up 47%
about I believe that's the language back
language Bank contract that Beth was
just speaking to now did I hear right
that the only language that we're really
emphasizing is Spanish though I mean or
or do we still need to do a lot of Edge
translations for Vital
documents hi this is Ann thank you for
that question I'm gonna ask Anella to
clarify again just because she has all
of the
knowledge I just remember that most of
it is Spanish but it didn't sound like
that was all of it
certainly so um thank you representative
Edwards um so for the vital document we
mean applications to services so those
are mostly done in Spanish however we
work closely with um office of refugee
resettlement and we look into the
language needs in certain
populations um um and um district
offices and we try to have forms
tailored into those languages that are
actually being resettled in the areas so
in the past when uh Vietnamese refugees
were coming we would get um also
Vietnamese language in addition to
Spanish then we had bosnians and
Sudanese so those will be the languages
that we will translate currently it's
Swahili uh kinanda and kirundi because
those are the groups that come from
Democratic Republic of Congo um so we
try to work with the department needs
and make sure that the vital documents
are available into those predominantly
High utilization languages so so thank
you for all of that those are vital
Services I'm I'm glad you're working on
it I I'm just I'm just doing some
accounting here there's a a line called
contracts for program Services which
sounds like would be the language bank
money and it goes up about
97,000 but for the overall General funds
it's going up
34,000 so the language Bank looks like
it's accounting for about a third of the
plus up in the general
fund and I'm just curious if I'm
interpreting that right and if I am
where's where's the other two3 what's
going
on it's benefits
maybe and personal
services okay all
right so does that look right to you uh
C I'm I'm not going to do your name well
miss cruche
crucia thank you um yes so the office of
Health Equity didn't have the
communication access contract within our
office when that moved our budget
certainly looks different I think this
is the first time that office the
finance committee can see the difference
when it moved from Bureau of family
assistance I do believe that's the only
change I don't think it's associated
with translation
say thank you for that are there any
other questions about this line item so
so just out of curiosity you're you're
you're you're refer Folks at DHHS are
referring to this is is the office of
equity is there a point where the the
name in the spreadsheet is going to
change and and what's required to make
that happen
it's a good question so
um we um we do have the ability to
change the names of accounting units but
sometimes uh Department of
administrative Services decides that the
change is uh such a different name that
it requires putting it in an entirely
different accounting unit which then
means that you start to lose the history
of that accounting unit so we're very
careful about when we actually make
those changes to make sure that they're
permanent long-term changes because
otherwise we could go bium to bium as
those who have been on the committee a
long time now and end up moving things
back and forth and creating um more
confusion so we do regularly try to
update those um but
uh sometimes we leave them at the older
names and just explain why it's an older
name sure okay so I I'm I'm I'm anti
chaos I like I like that I like having
historical yeah so um but I'm also
conventional enough to want the names to
match that if we're going to call
ourselves one thing it should be that
way everywhere but but that's that's a
that's an operational problem I would um
I I can certainly talk chat with Kevin
too I don't know what the history has
been as far as changing the names in the
legislative po process to know if that's
a possibility um but I I will have that
conversation with him and with
administrative services and and see what
that would look like yeah and just so
you know why I I mean I'm trainable
everyone on this call now understands
exactly what you guys have done um but
for public transparency into the budget
I I just I just think we we should have
consistent naming so that the public
knows what we're doing I understand and
totally appreciate that all right so so
is the next one Refugee
Services is that the next one down yes
yes it is 79 72 I'm sorry
7209 and that quick
question yes uh yes I didn't I'm sorry I
didn't see your hand go ahead repres
okay Karen is it is there some way to
determine the ordering of the
spreadsheet to the ordering in the book
you're looking at because they're not in
the same order there something that
would help me map them like alphabet
alization or something
else I do not have an answer to why the
order is the way it is okay so they're
put out different totally different ways
basically um I that would definitely be
an administrative Services question I do
not know okay
thanks so this is 100% Federal funded is
that right this this area Refugee
Services it is yes and are we calling
this Equity now too or is this remaining
Refugee Services th this is part of the
office of Health Equity yes okay but
this is a smart guy tell me never change
the name as long as they're funding
it um but yes this is the refugee
Services Grant um that is part of the
office of calac
the opposite was true is if they stop
funding it you need to change the
name um I try not to use to use tricks
like that but I understand the said do
it all right so
um so then I think so since this is not
our money I don't know if we're asking a
lot of questions on this
section um I assume it's all well
managed and no
problems that is my understanding I do
not know of any issues in that
area so then um I'm just pulling up back
to
the the spreadsheet that shows um all of
the oom accounting units so the other
ones that we talked about tomorrow are
here highlighted in green so we're going
to jump ahead to
5677 which is on page 1,177
okay Bureau of human Affair or human
resources yes
sir okay so the Personnel are saying
constant this is where
um a as Deputy Commissioner Weaver
mentioned earlier we do budget a lot of
the training for the Department which is
in M
66 I I don't have any questions here
does anyone on the committee have
questions for the Bureau of Human
Resources seeing
none what's
next the next one is 5685 which is
management support this is uh one of the
facilities
um accounting
units man
this one the general fund's going up
29% $3
million say that again I'm sorry so I'm
sorry I probably had my hand over my
mouth I uh this one is going up 29% or
over $3 million on the general
funds so uh what's going on here this is
a pretty big jump a material one so part
of the increase is class line 28 which
is transfer to General services that is
increasing
$400,000 um that is one of the larger
increases um there's also uh class line
48 um which did not have any cost in
20 um that is going
up and so Dave and Beth Dave clab could
you speak a little bit to the increases
and then Beth maybe you can add a little
bit about the general funds
piece um one of the increases were was
the uh transfer to D maintenance for
future maintenance projects that's based
against their square footage cost and I
forget what the actual dollar value
would they use per square
foot um water and electricity uh we're
actually taking a drop from from um this
fiscal year into the next fiscal year
we've done a lot of there's been a lot
of energy improvements that we're going
through to try to keep them um operating
as efficiently as
possible uh
telecommunications the that's some cell
phones and so forth
um because most of the uh phones have
been transferred over to the other that
we spoke about
earlier one that jumps out at me is the
rents leases other than State going from
going up about
888,246 district office so okay so so
let me let me ask you uh a question
related to what's going on in the
corporate world I I I hear corporations
are trying to use the fact that they've
downsized their people through
telecommuting so much that they're
aggressively renegotiating the amount of
rental space they need and so Corporate
America is cutting their rents uh now I
believe and so ours are going up a lot
and I'm just curious if if maybe there's
an opportunity here for us to make some
money and reduce our
rents we always go up for RFP and we go
for the best uh price that we can get uh
for a rent uh
figure so we've always address that the
unit the the ones that we're having to
address the three District offices do
have are older and the leases are at the
end of their um time so they were a
10year lease when we got them and we're
g to try to reduce the
space as much as we can but we we're
still working on what the numbers are uh
that are coming back representative
Rogers has her hand up you're recognized
yes um Karen answer this and if this is
the but I remember in the last budget we
had a whole rigal we talked about I
think the Rochester office and we went
back and forth about um space that we
were getting from the city then we
weren't getting it then we were looking
at new space and I wondered has that
been resolved is that still one of the
ones we're negotiating where does that
stand and what's going on with that rent
or that lease that has not been resolved
at this
time so where do we stand what's
happening
uh we're actually filing for a twoyear
exension to allow us to
re-evaluate um the office and any
um potential new locations that we can
go to um the city was not happy in that
the the standard has changed for
district offices considerably so the
we've been there for almost 20 years and
um it didn't the safeguards put in place
and the meeting space for uh to meet
with clients was below standard and
doesn't meet Ada um accessibility
standards if I could follow up please um
I think would it be possible for you to
maybe get to us a um recap from I think
I have my paperwork somewhere but it
would be easier Kevin um if maybe you
could get to us the recap of where we
stood two years ago
with some of that material and bring us
up to date with a brief memo of what's
going on over there and and where we
stand would be helpful yep sure I can do
that thank you very
much so so do is that all your questions
representative Rogers I don't want to
stop you thank you very much you're very
welcome so Mr clap I'm now looking at
the transfers to General Services that's
up about 885,000 on average 15%
increase yes that's dictated To Us by uh
Das um they have a group uh Bureau of
facilities and assets management that's
supposed to manage the properties on the
Sops campus off of uh Pleasant Street
and they dictate what the costs are that
we're we're giving
them so so I'm I'm just going to say it
back to see if I heard you right that
that this is
essentially a a a contract that we're
paying for so that they maintain our
buildings on a
campus yes it's similar to paying the
rent they basically take their expenses
for the buildings and the whole campus
and um charges for that and is this
Federal General services or is this aate
General services this is uh the
department of administrative Services
Bureau of facilities and assets
management it's not General
Services because it says transfers to
General Services I was just wondering if
that was a a a federal effort or or if
we have our own state level it's the
state
level and what would account for that
just they're charging us more or because
they can or or because uh the buildings
are in disrepair and and repair fits
within this line the repairs are within
that um because of covid a lot of stuff
was uh pushed off and now U they've got
to catch up the the buildings are old
they do need maintenance that has to be
addressed so it's it's pretty much just
to make sure that the buildings can be
utilized who whose responsibility is it
to take a look at our entire building
inventory and decide what should just be
torn down and built new who who who does
who owns that
plan that there was a master plan done
uh by um admin
services and there was some buildings
have been slated to be torn down which
uh we're in the process of having the
Steam Plant demolished um some other
buildings were amach to be demolished
but we're looking at uh get trying to
get them repurposed so that we can have
office space that can be used
properly so is that within DHHS or is
that a state function that's um who does
it that is Das Department of
administrative services
Kevin which division is Department of
administrative Services part
of I'm sorry it's division
one all right hey thank you Mr clap do
you have are are you and Miss rounds
going to do another department with
us I believe so one more yes the
district offices
5657 5687 87 I'm sorry 5687
this is an area where we did um leave
the instate travel reimbursement hire
because these are people who are
traveling to the district offices and
helping service them so that that's
unlikely to change even with less people
in the office as long as the office
exists people will have to go to them to
maintain
them okay
anyone have questions on this
section the dhh district office just
remind me are these the 13 or so offices
around the state or is this one in
conquered these are located throughout
the state there is one in conquered but
it is located throughout the
state is Berlin little in
Conway uh
Rochester uh SE Coast which is in
Portsmouth um Southern which is in
nashor the Manchester Keane and
Claymont I think I the answer to
division
trivia that houses all the divisions
that um provide services to
clients any any questions from the
committee on DHHS district
office all
right thank you thank you okay so that
um that concludes all of the accounting
units for the presentations that we went
over this morning it leaves three
accounting units in um in office of the
commissioner two which are highlighted
here in this uh blue color which are uh
Meredith too um and the one in purple
which is Bureau of Information
Services so I'm gonna go ahead and stop
sharing for now um let's talk about
tomorrow a little bit um Monday Monday
yeah that tomorrow Monday
um let let's let's do it like we did
legal today where where we start at the
at the overview and work our way just
straight down all the way through the
accounting lines um so that may shift is
back further but it would release uh the
quality people a little sooner also so
what what do you what do you think about
that I think that works so you're
thinking that let's do quality and
Information Services on Monday and and
wrap up for
today yes okay yeah that will work
fine so um so because I I know that uh
representative wer had had a 3:30 uh so
you're you're out way early very good
and I I think that also makes a lot of
sense because both of those
presentations do um deserve some time
they're they're both very weighty and
have a lot of information and um I think
it would be great to give them the time
that they they would really need to give
you an understanding so you've seen our
Pace now do do do you think uh if
starting at 9:30 on Monday that will be
done by 3 or so or what do you think yes
absolutely we might even get to take
more than a 20- minute lunch and still
be done by three 22 minutes
representative wer don't we always have
a a Monday morning chair Vice chair
meetings I think we may be in the
calendar at this point uh but you're
you're you're right but I think our
kickoff is at 9:30 in the calendar
it is just just so you know
representative if you did want to open
that meeting at 9:30 and then recess
until a later time you could do that so
I could defer our start till 10: without
running into a calendaring
problem if you if we were to open up at
9:30 and you were to come on and say
you're recessing until 10 yes
absolutely yes so I I haven't I haven't
attended one of those um Monday morning
meetings for a while so it might be nice
to know what's going on
yeah all right so so um let's let's plan
is that okay with you miss R you've got
that sounds great yeah I think Pace wise
we're we're doing fine you had today and
um Monday slided slated for office the
commissioner um I will also let you know
I just had a moment to read through my
emails and Mary khis in the background
as she often does is working on uh
putting together a list of all of the
positions that moved throughout the
department so that will answer your
questions for all those smaller moves
that did happen um so we'll work on that
and get that to you I will work to get
you the briefing book um tomorrow and
then also the comparison uh the 3,000
lines of information that I was talking
about for 18 19 and 20 and comparing to
2223 um early next
week good so you'll you'll have
something to
do always
always so uh all right well um
before we hang up does anyone have
anything for the good of the
effort Jonah you've sat there quietly
all day you got to have something no no
representative I've been writing down
your request so I have been doing I've
been doing things don't worry okay I
think representative F has as well so I
don't I don't know how you're going to
coordinate representative Earth are you
coordinating with with Mr Ripple or Mr
Fel
we're coordinating with regard to
questions you've been keeping track of
questions too I was going to put them
together for you and let you deal with
them as you see
fit I can't hear you copy copy Mr Ripple
and Mr felstein if you wouldn't mind
very
well right that and Jonah when you send
those over if you could send them to
Mary kis and I I would be very
appreciative I I believe Kevin will
probably be the one sending him over
right Kevin
yeah sure we'll figure that
out one
one did you have more sir one thing I
did pick up in a Governor's briefing
they all these uh class 10 have gone up
10% which I think is
unreasonable but part of and the thing
they added to it and you need to confirm
this with this department as well is
they going up roughly 2% everybody's
wages either step increases or contract
they're going up five % over medical
insurance which we're self-insured I'm I
don't understand how that's happened we
haven't gone up at all County and 3%
because of the incompetence of the New
Hampshire retirement system they got to
we're not falling in line with
our 30-year plan and we're about 12 13
years into it and uh so the Investments
that they're putting things in are are
not getting a very good return yet
they're still assuming like
6.75 which means that they're getting
further and further away from what they
should be in the funding for that
retirement system so these are things
that are endemic across the whole system
that needs to be addressed at a higher
level with the uh Governor's U budget
guy and I don't think I think they
should be able to do something about
that 5% increase in the health insurance
either reduce what they're delivering or
go to a different coordinator I think
even though we're self-insured I think
they hire a third party toh manage that
obviously there's not a very good job if
it's gone up that much so some things we
got to deal with that are outside of the
control of this Division and and this
agency if if they're not going to
control those things at the higher level
so
unfortunately we don't have that much we
don't have a 10% increase in Revenue so
we're still stuck with searching for
savings do do you have an update on when
Ways and Means might send us um their
first
guess not till the 23rd is is last I
heard February 23rd or March 23rd I'm
sorry February 23rd okay all right and
and then and then is it the practice of
the finance committee to split that out
to give the division
targets
yes okay very good like to see how much
we can we can come in how close we can
come but you know it's it's going to be
tough uh I've got a
plan over in division two you know
they're talking about a $50
million uh education trust fund
Surplus we don't need to have a surplus
in a fund that we need to use everywhere
else and since education Trust TR fund
comes out of the the general fund
sources we need to change the
percentages from the sources so that 50
million doesn't go to a surplus we need
to spend it in this budget thank
you all right anything else
sir representative wer if you got
anything no that that's all I have thank
you okay representative
Rogers do you have anything for us
representative nordgren thanks for
sticking sticking through the whole
thing uh Harry you there representative
Bean would you check out on
us all right so with that I'll uh I'll
I'll I'll go ahead I don't need a motion
to reset or no not to adjourn thank you
for giving me time to get ready for the
fiscal all right well thank you so much
for uh your time today take care goodbye
bye